bien mesdames et messieurs mes chers
collègues merci
d'avoir répondu à l'invitation merci au
président farandou d'être à nos côtés
pour ce pour cette audition que
j'ai souhaité organiser
dans le cadre notamment du contrat
performance
merci à lui d'être d'être à nos côtés et
c'est avec plaisir que nous
l'accueillons ce matin et monsieur le
président directeur général depuis près
de trois ans à la suite de votre
nomination à la tête du groupe d'abord
en tant que président du directoire de
la sncf puis en qualité de président
directeur général nous sommes
particulièrement attachés à vous
recevoir annuellement
pour recevoir pour faire le point sur
les nombreux enjeux auxquels est
confronté le groupe public unifié
d'abord et vous ne serez pas surpris je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur le
nouveau contrat de performance et entre
l'état et sncf réseau
contre-performance qui a été signée en
avril
je dois dire que nous avons toutes et
tous
et est particulièrement mécontent à la
fois sur la forme
puisque nous avons découvert par voie de
presse qu'il avait été signé mais aussi
surtout sur le fond nous avions à
plusieurs je salue notre collègue
jacquin qui nous retrouver
nous avions pas plusieurs occasions de
même que les principaux acteurs du
secteur à commencer par leurs
régulateurs fait part de nombreuses
réserves quant au projet de contrat
aurait en dépit des différentes
consultations et des nombreuses
suggestions d'évolution nous avons été
au regret de constater que le document
final n'avait quasiment pas évolué par
rapport au projet soumis à la
consultation
il ya de quoi s'interroger sur l'intérêt
porté à ces consultations nous sommes
salut ça va nous sommes d'autant plus
inquiets compte tenu de l'inflation
galopante qui est susceptible de réduire
encore davantage de niveau voire même le
périmètre de régénération du réseau que
nous avions déjà estimé insuffisant je
suis conscient et je ne m'adresse pas et
au président directeur général de sncf
le gestionnaire d'infrastructure qui est
partie prenante de ce contrat mais à
celui de la sncf c'est pourquoi ma
question est la suivante dans ce constat
est dans ce contexte avec des moyens
aussi contraint me semble-t-il toujours
possible d'atteindre nos objectifs
ambitieux de développement du mode
ferroviaire
pour rappel la loi climat résidence fixé
l'objectif de doubler la part modale du
fret ferroviaire et d'augmenter celle du
transport ferroviaire de voyageurs de
17% d'ici 2030 et de 42 pour cent d'ici
je crois avoir une idée de votre réponse
puisque vous avez récemment estimé le
besoin 100 milliards d'euros sur 15 ans
d'après vous quels sont les leviers pour
parvenir à cet objectif
en complément et plus particulièrement
sur le volet voyageurs pouvaient vous
monsieur le président nous indiquer
quelles sont les mesures envisagées par
la sncf en matière de politique
commerciale et tarifaire pour encourager
l'usagé du train plutôt que celui de la
voiture ou de l'avion et ainsi réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
liées aux transports qui reste le
premier secteur émetteur
en l'état actuel des choses et malgré un
record les prix élevés des billets
peuvent parfois découragés a soit
choisir le train plutôt qu'un autre mode
de transport en second lieu à notre
commission souhaiterait vous entendre
sur le déroulement de l'ouverture à la
concurrence
du transport conventionnés des services
librement organisé cette évolution
affecte toutes les entités composant le
groupe public unifié notamment sncf
réseau qui se doit d'être indépendant et
sncl voyageurs qui est confronté à
l'arrivée de nouveaux entrants ainsi que
la politique salariale du groupe oc
pourriez vous nous faire un point
d'étape puisqu'il est trop tôt pour en
faire le bilan sur toutes ses premières
années d'ouverture à la concurrence
enfin je souhaiterais rappeler que
l'ouverture à la concurrence n'est pas
le seul grand bouleversement à l'oeuvre
ces dernières années cette mutation se
sont ajoutés non seulement l'impact de
la crise sanitaire sur le transport
ferroviaire mais aussi d'autres
difficultés je ne souhaiterais en
évoquer 2,9 en vous d'abord la période
estivale été marquée par des pics de
très fortes chaleurs qui ont eu des
répercussions importantes sur l'état du
réseau et on revient ici au premier
point que j'évoquais le contrat de
performance et donc sur la circulation
des trains plus globalement ces
événements pose la question de
l'adaptation aux changements climatiques
de notre réseau ferroviaire
pourriez vous revenir sur ces épisodes
et sur les mesures de mise en oeuvre par
le groupe pour y faire face mais aussi
pour s'y préparer en amont
ensuite et en lien avec la question de
l'inflation que je mentionnais à
l'instant et dans le contexte actuel de
crise de l'énergie la sncf qui est une
très grande consommatrice d'électricité
pourraient potentiellement être
confrontés à des épisodes de pénurie
d'électricité comment la sncf se
prépare-t-elle à faire face à cette
situation le président je ne serai pas
pu on est je vous laisse à présent la
parole avant de la donner à mes
collègues qui je n'en doute pas auront
un certain nombre de questions à vous
poser le président directeur général je
ne lis lettre papale c'est évident merci
beaucoup pour votre audition et
nombreuses questions j'avais préparé
quelques unes à mon propos liminaire gsm
et peut-être de développer un petit peu
plus les angles que vous avez abordé je
commence par saluer bien sûr du
président d'abord et les sénatrices et
les sénateurs qui me font la gentillesse
de lâcher que ça vous a bousculé peu
dans la gêne a donc j'apprécie encore
plus votre présence est encore plus
quand je vois que certains ont le bras
en écharpe donc je mesure l'intérêt que
vous portez que vous portez à ces sujets
dans merci je sais que je suis vous le
souhaitez mais je me plie bien
volontiers je trouve précieux est normal
à la fois d'avoir au moins une fois par
an l'occasion d'échanger avec vous je
pense que je souhaite avoir justement
des concertations des échanges d'une
écoute régulière avec leurs voisins
nationale et les territoires à comme que
vous représentez c1 paraît absolument
indispensable peut-être à cette occasion
et vous l'avez évoqué d'abord je
m'exprimerai et ça c'est bien je crois
que le point de vue est important au
fond mon rôle à l'orée du grand c'est
d'être au delà des ccf réseau et qui
doit s'occuper du réseau de l'année ces
voyageurs qui doit développer trafic
voyageurs et fret idem moi je suis au
fond en tant que président en ensemble
garant garant devant les français devant
la représentation du bon fonctionnement
du système ferroviaire français
aujourd'hui et demain en intégrant à la
fois une ambition mais qui doit être
proposé au gouvernement c'est bien
gouvernement de porter une ambition
politique pour le réseau ferroviaire
français est bien sûr en intégrant le
facteur coût à un coût le plus
raisonnable possible pour les
contribuables français comment qu'elle
sera l'éclairage finalement transversale
de mon de mon expression peut-être vous
l'avez évoqué me permettrai jeu parce
que ça passe vite le temps déjà presque
trois ans effectivement je faisais pas
vu passer mais bon parce que l'actualité
a été riche mais ça permet aussi d'avoir
un petit recul de regarder un peu ce qui
a été fait pour mieux se projeter sur
sur l'avenir
bon la caractéristique c'est qu'on a
vécu des crises ça vous l'avez rappelé
on a commencé par une crise sociale sur
la réforme des retraites enfin le
parallèle avec ce qui pourrait se passer
dans les prochains mois ou à peine la
crise qu vide sanitaire la renier tous
tombés dedans mais la mobilité et le
ferroviaire a été bien sûr très
impactées par les coups d'accordéon
confinement déconfinement qu'il a fallu
organiser pour protéger la santé de nos
voyageurs et aussi de nos personnels ne
faut pas l'oublier
et puis on est en train de commencer à
vivre la crise économique consécutive à
la crise géopolitique de l'ukraine avec
comme vous le voyez bien sur l'inflation
l'énergie les matières premières même
des crises d'approvisionnement sur
certains éléments techniques nécessaires
par exemple aux travaux au matériel
roulant on est en train de rentrer dans
une nouvelle crise dont on connaît pas
bien ni la dynamique ni l'intensité ni
la durée voilà donc un facteur
d'incertitude important devons nous
rappeler aussi que cette période elle
est marquée quand même par la mise en
oeuvre d'une loi qui a été votée au
parlement le nouveau pacte ferroviaire
qui a créé sept 7 noeuds ce nouvel
ensemble
avec donc des sociétés anonymes et plus
d epic ce qui est pas complètement
neutre et qui peut expliquer parfois des
attitudes un peu plus un peu plus faire
je tire de l'eau de l'univers sncf le
rapport à telle demande économique
puisque nous sommes dans des mandataires
sociaux responsables de la dette etc etc
donc on voit bien qu'à et ça a été
voulue une mise en responsabilité forte
plus forte des dirigeants sncf sur ces
sujets là c'est la reprise de la dette
35 milliards d'euros on s'en réjouit
mais c'est aussi au même moment une
trajectoire économique rigoureuse de
retour à l'équilibré que nous sommes en
train aussi de réaliser malgré les
difficultés rencontrées c'est la fin du
recrutement statut qui est pas comment
notre à la fois culturellement et puis
dans la dynamique de l'entreprise et
c'est enfin la clarification de la
concurrence on s'était attendu en france
l'état a pris ses responsabilités en
décrivant plus précisément comment la
concurrence allait se mettre en oeuvre
dans notre pays à la fois dans les
régions et ile-de-france mobilité ou
dans la partie librement organisé voilà
ça c'est la loi
peut-être vous dire aussi que
on a réussi dans la période et c'est une
thématique que vous avez vous avait
effleuré c'est mal gré d'un ensemble ces
transformations importantes à préserver
un dialogue social on va dire
correct voilà il faut aussi trouver le
bon adjectif à mais correct ce qui est
en soi un progrès par rapport à la
période précédente on se parle on se
parle on s'écoute on se respecte
d'ailleurs à part la grève de retraite
mais qui était pas spécifique à la sncf
qui était une grève de l'ensemble du
pays il n'y a pas eu de grève national
de forte depuis presque trois ans il ya
quelques conflits locaux je ne dis pas
que tout est sereine partout mais on a
au moins évité le blocage du pays par le
dialogue social mais voilà correct voilà
et est en voie de progrès même je
n'oserais le dire ont même si bien
évidemment tout et tout est fragile et
tout est susceptible de 2,2 réaction
vous dire aussi que et c'est peut-être
un élément aussi que j'aime bien donner
parce que c'est peut-être aussi une
perception qu'il faut avoir sncf on
connaît tous ses aspects ferroviaire
bien sûr tous français on prend le train
donc l'aspect ferroviaire est connue ce
qui est moins connu c'est glacé c'est un
groupe aussi à une entreprise qui est un
groupe dont la moitié du chiffre
d'affaires n'est pas le ferroviaire
français la moitié du chiffre d'affaires
du groupe s'est geodis qui à pris d'or
beaucoup d'efforts pendant pendant
pendant ces dernières c'est d'ailleurs à
neydens et les échanges internationaux
de marchandises de fret dans des
containers en particulier et donc on a
la chance en france d'avoir un opérateur
public puisque 100% sncf donc contrôlée
par l'état qui est un des grands
champions la logistique mondiale c'est
important pour souveraineté industrielle
pour les entreprises françaises et puis
on à keolis aussi peut-être certains
d'entre vous le connaissent dans vos
territoires qui est une grande
entreprise transports urbains métro
tramway bus cars dont la moitié du
chiffre d'affaires aussi ce fait
l'international avec des grandes
réussites comme droit comme dubaï comme
melbourne comme boston enfin voila c'est
un champion industriel français qui
connaît aussi les succès à l'export et
les cet ensemble là pour vous donner un
ordre de grandeur parce que j'aime bien
et les équivalences et on a beaucoup
parlé on en parle maintenant de la
fusion veolia suez on dire grands
champions des services aux collectivités
qui se met en place et bien le groupe
sncf c'est l'équivalent chez d'affaires
ces 40 milliards d'euros par an qui vous
voyez un peu l'ensemble industriel dont
on parle on parle pas de c'est quand
même un ensemble de poids voilà je le
dis parce que parfois c'est quelque
chose qui est pas présent dans la tête
et ses 220 mille collaborateurs cent
cinquante mille cheminots à lire dans le
ferroviaire français et 70 villes dans
l'est dans les grandes filiales
le maillon économies que vous l'avez un
joli rappeler la loi 2008 le premier
c'est cette année la loi prévoit que
nous soyons à l' équilibre économique
globale du groupe en 2022 c'est à la
sncf et ses filiales nous le serons sauf
catastrophe vraiment bon là on est quand
même bien de toi en octobre bombe avant
les chiffres pour le moment on est même
en avance on est même en avance donc
c'est déjà une bonne nouvelle par
rapport à l'engagement qui avait été
pris par les cdc de tenir cette
trajectoire eh bien on sera au premier
rang des
après on verra les nuages qui
s'accumulent mais ce premier rendez vous
il sera tenu
dire aussi que
finalement vous savez quand on en est
quand on devienne président d'une
entreprise assez rapidement il faut
fixer un cap si on fixe pas de cap
l'entreprise voguant sur les flots bon
il est ainsi le rôle peut-être le
premier rôle on le rôle essentiel d'un
président de tenir bon le cap c'est là
c'est une prise de risques parce que
surtout dans un monde aussi mouvant qui
est le nôtre mais bon et à travers ce
cap j'ai souhaité donner 4 4 axes forts
à l'action générale de la sncf la
première je pense qu'elle vous fera
plaisir j'espère que vous commencez à la
percevoir ces les territoires que les
cff se tourner davantage dans les
territoires apprennent à mieux
travailler avec les territoires bien sûr
les régions en premier lieu mais pas que
les régions les métropoles les villes
les départements en fait qu'est une
capacité de la sncf à mieux s'interfacer
avec les collectivités locales on va
dire terme générique de notre pays
deuxièmement l'environnement ça paraît
alors ça c'était il ya trois ans mais ça
paraît de plus en plus évident mais il
ya trois ans ça commençait à arriver
quand même et c'était évident pour moi
que la sncf devaient se positionner
comme un acteur majeur de la transition
écologique dans notre pays par son
métier de mobilité mais aussi plus que
ça on le verra troisièmement l'humain
lui magie tient d'abord à titre
personnel je pense que c'est une valeur
assez largement partagé avec vous cent
cinq ans mais cheminots en pleine
transformation
faut les accompagner quoi vous avez
parlé concurrence monsieur le président
c'est un choc pour les cheminots c'est
pas quelque chose qui se
keith admet se comprend facilement folle
folle folle folle accepté il faut
l'admettre faut pas leur envoyer que
c'est facile tout ça voilà donc il faut
s'en occuper il faut d'écouté il faut
dialoguer et puis ce sont des salariés
ils ont aussi des problèmes de
conditions de travail de pouvoir d'achat
en ce moment etc etc donc je pense que
l' approche humaine par rapport aux
salariés et est dispensable mais aussi
on peut faire le pendant pour les
clients aussi les clients aussi sont des
êtres humains il faut les sans occuper
bien ça l'occupé vous avez soulevé les
aspects tarifaires les aspects de
qualité de service etc ce devrait être
aussi au coeur de notre nom au travail
et enfin lancer une tradition j'allais
dire sncf dont le
propos la preuve principal a été les
mentions du tgv c'est l'innovation la
sncf est une entreprise innovante
il faut absolument qu'on regarde ce
caractère c'est à dire du progrès
scientifique du progrès technique c'est
une entreprise qui croît au progrès
technique qui croient aux apports de la
technologie pour améliorer les services
pour améliorer l'efficacité pour voilà
pour pour penser le ferroviaire de
demain on a besoin d'innovation
technologique ces quatre thèmes là mais
ils sont toujours là ils sont toujours
là trois ans plus tard je pense qu'il ya
ya aucun d'entre eux que je voudrais
enlevé on peut rajouter l'énergétique ça
ça il ya trois ans on n'avait pas des
sujets d'énergie ils se sont ils ont
fait irruption dans le débat public tout
à coup on se rendre compte que l'énergie
c'est rare c'est cher on n'est pas sûr
d'en avoir on a même à se demander si on
pourra chauffer cet hiver là c'est quand
même ce cas une question qu'on se posait
pas il ya trois ans on pensait pas que
ça allait nous arriver en france en
europe de se dire on risque de pas
pouvoir se chauffer suffisamment en tout
cas cet hiver quand même ça une
perspective qui vient changer quand même
la donne en profondeur avec les aspects
économiques qui vont avec ça a été
effleurée aussi par le président loulou
c'est que l'énergie coûte plus cher
voilà qu'est ce que ça veut dire dans
l'est dans les comptes d'une entreprise
et dans la répercussion éventuelle dans
le prix pour les pour les usagers j'y
reviendrai dans le développement voilà
donc tout ça on là devant nous
et là où je suis un petit peu audacieux
mais choix qu'il faut l'être c'est
qu'alors que ça c'est un peu des menaces
c'est des menaces et des nuages moi j'y
vois aussi une opportunité voire une
obligation voir une vision c'est que en
fait il faut il faut traverser les
difficultés qui sont devant nous on n'a
pas le choix mais il faut surtout pas
renoncer au monde de demain surtout pas
donc moi je suis très attentif et c'est
un débat de fond à ce que le traitement
de l'urgence et du court terme nous
fassent oublier les enjeux de demain ils
l'enjeu principal de demers le connaît
tous et la transition écologique si on
ne fait rien ou pas suffisamment nous
allons on a à peu près tout ce certains
puits sont plus jeunes que d'autres
voilà tous à peu près la même tranche
d'âge on est en responsabilité à les
gens qui ont 50 ans quand 60 ans qu'est
ce qu'on fait pour laisser à nos enfants
et nos petits enfants une planète
vivable c'est aussi simple que ça le
sujet et on voit bien que l'été qui est
passé nous montre que les dangers sont
réels c'est pas ils sont pas
inventer inondations sécheresses grandes
chaleurs à nouveau les incendies
d'environ etc etc etc le réchauffement
climatique est en train de changer les
conditions de vie sur notre planète
voilà il est encore temps d'agir et
c'est ingrat parce qu'il faut agir
maintenant pour des effets plus tard
donc ya pas le parfois le résultat
immédiat de l'action mais si on n'a pas
le courage de décider et d'agir
maintenant bah c'est une responsabilité
lourde que nous prenons vis-à-vis des
générations futures
ma réponse à ça là où je suis je reviens
à mon rôle de ferroviaire 1 46e
ferroviaire c'est une ambition forte je
sais qu'elle a été reprise est en passe
dans un trou et je les en remercie parce
que j'ai besoin de soutien si je suis
tout seul je n'arriverais pas si on est
plusieurs on a une chance c'est le x 2 1
le foie de ces deux fois plus de
marchandises dans les trains deux fois
plus de voyageurs dans les trains voilà
c'est la réponse c'est prendre dix
points et et comprend ou à la route la
route et le monde dominant ira tourner
la route parce que la route fait 85 %
des déplacements c'est le même chiffre à
peu près pour les marchandises et pour
les voyageurs au moins c'est simple je
dis pas que demain le train pourra tout
prendre c'est impossible mais moi mon
ambition c'est prendre dix points à la
haute qui se rajoute aux dix points
qu'on a déjà disputé segal bengale foi
de ces la mathématique que tout le monde
peut comprendre bon ce qui d'ailleurs
les sentiers mais ça c'est pas mon sujet
le verdissement de la route à il faudra
bien s'attaquer au verdissement de la
route si l'on la route continuera à
polluer donc oui il faut il ya aussi les
chantiers mais qui n'est pas l'objet de
mon intervention mais que j'admets
complètement il faudra bien se demander
comment je vais redit les voitures ça
c'est en cours même si c'est pas simple
le verdissement des camions de vous à
moi il n'y a pas grand chose qui bouge
parce que c'est compliqué voilà non mais
ça je vous disais au passage parlons du
train comment comment on y arrive alors
il ya ya ya deux étapes du raisonnement
là il ya le raisonnement il ya là
heureusement physique et le heureusement
finances rayon physique services
financiers le physique c'est le réseau
le réseau d'aujourd'hui il n'est pas
capable de faire x 2 mais alors pas du
tout et d'ailleurs même même si a pas de
développement sur ça n'occupe pas il va
se paupériser ce réseau c'est la faute à
faire c'est pas la faute à vous c'est
pas la faute au gouvernement actuel
c'est un héritage du passé on connaît
l'histoire si je la résume le tgv a
absorbé tout l'angola grande partie de
la la substance économique de la sncf
qui pendant des décennies n'a pas mis
assez d'argent sur le réseau ferroviaire
classique voilà certains le savent et
beaucoup ont tourné la tête abandonnée
on est rattrapé par la réalité et ça
c'est leur première réponse et premier
raccroche par rapport aux contrats de
performance
je vais le dire avec des mots diplomate
contrat de performance en est ravie
qu'il existe mais à l'évidence les deux
milliards 8 sur fonds propres sncf
d'ailleurs sncf réseau attention là
aussi il ya parfois des idées un peu
confuse 2 milliards 8 oui sur fonds
propres des cncf réseau c'est pas
l'argent qui sort du budget de l'état 2
milliards à vide et ncf réseau c'est pas
assez c'est pas suffisant pour aller au
au bout d'une ambition forte d'une
régénération consistante substantielle
de la de la matière du réseau et
l'indicateur grand public c'est le
scellage moyens voilà on est on est deux
fois plus vieux camp suisse et en
allemagne héééé auryn du contrat de
performance on ne redresse pas la courbe
on en fait on ralentit l'érosion on ne
redresse pas l'âge l'âge moyen donc il
faut mettre plus d'argent pour non
seulement à limiter l'érosion mais
revenir à une trajectoire positive ou
petit à petit petit à petit à petit on
arrivera parce qu'il faut les années
pour faire ça dans la durée on arrivera
à avoir un état du réseau satisfaisant
l'enjeu c'est la fiabilité les pannes
les passages à niveau les caténaires qui
casse vous avez parlé des grandes
chaleurs pourquoi on réduit la vitesse
dans le sud ouest à une sénatrice des
pyrénées atlantiques pourquoi on réduit
la vitesse pour aller à pau parce que
alors j'ai décidé moi de faire un peu de
technique on a dû 400 volts de bordeaux
a sur l'île nouvelle c'est lui verser
1000 volts à partir de bordeaux c'est
les anciennes lignes élancées de
caténaire caténaire du midi elles sont
60 à 70 ans voilà donc sont ce qu'elles
sont et bien c'est lui qui s'envole de
15 ans vol ça chauffe beaucoup c'est du
courant continu il faut réduire la
vitesse des trains sont réduits par
éviter d'être elle claque et ont préféré
allonger les temps de parcours de
manière structurée organisée c'est pas
forcément satisfaisant pour les clients
mais en la prévenant etc sinon on risque
d'incident caténaires et là ça roule
plus du tout voilà donc et ça a marché
entre guillemets on a pas eu d'incident
caténaire majeur sur le sud-ouest qui
prouve c'est une bonne mesure mais qui
dont l'amant de la source racines je te
revient la vétusté du réseau ce navet
des caténaires 9 vous seul avez des
caténaires verser 1000 volts on pourrait
rouler à pleine vitesse tout l'été pour
aller pour aller à pau voilà donc c'est
ça le sujet dont fiabilité limite
sécurité je pense qu'on joue pas avec la
sécurité m'ont semblé au bout d'un
moment que d'un réseau trop vétuste peut
finir par ne pas présenter toutes les
garanties nécessaires
voilà faut faire attention alors bien
sûr on y ont visiblement préfère baisser
la vitesse par exemple voire supprimer
la circulation des trains puisque le
prendrais sécurité mais on sent bien ja
s'est pas complètement sans lien entre
l'état général du réseau et et le niveau
de sécurité qu'on peut proposer aux
trains et donc aux gens qui le prennent
donc ça c'est premièrement deuxièmement
quand on a fait ça on il ya aussi un
second sujet nous sommes en train de
prendre du retard j'ai obligé parler de
technique et de technologie partout en
europe ou dans la plupart des grands
pays il ya des nouvelles technologies
qui arrive sur le réseau ferroviaire
plus d'efficacité plus de modernité
c'est le digital la belgique est équipé
la suisse est équipé l'allemagne est en
train de le faire l'italie le fait bon
ou non
est ce grave docteur ben un peu quand
même parce que en termes de 2,2 niveau
technologique on va passer en seconde
division cas là on était en première
division on avait des meilleurs réseaux
d'europe et du monde si on fait pas les
sauts technologiques nécessaires en va
dégrader bon par exemple par exemple
digitalisées ça vous donne quoi c'est
calme et des effets c'est ce que vous
savez le
le rêve de tout de tout de tout est
génial c'est la maintenance prédictive
et remettre des capteurs un peu partout
sur les organes qui soit les matériels
roulants comme la voix est repéré quand
ça commence à vibrer de trop chauffer de
trop il ya intervenir avant que ça tombe
en panne ce qui fait qu à zéro panne et
c'est un rêve possible que la technique
rend possible mais pour faire sa faux
digitalisées peau du digital si vous
avez des postes d'aiguillage avait des
grands les grands leviers vous actionnez
avec une tringle qui fait bouger
l'aiguillé à 50 mètres ça vous pouvez
mettre tous les capteurs coué
y'aura pas trop d'intelligences
artificielles dessus quoi voilà donc la
digitalisation c'est une condition
absolument nécessaire à rentrer dans une
ère moderne du ferroviaire maintenance
prédictive et donc zéro panne moi si
j'avais tout équipé en digital je
pourrais m'engager devant vous à ce que
quand l'équipement serait fait dizaine
d'années quinzaine d'années la
régularité des trains passerait de 92
aujourd'hui à 95 96 97 en gros il répète
en technique alors on a toujours
quelques vaches qui quitteraient les
prêts ou quelques arabes qui tomberait
en cas de tempête malheureusement
quelques personnes qui font le choix de
finir leur vie sous un train ça ne
l'empêchera pas mais ça ferait que deux
ou trois points et vous imaginez le
niveau de performance on était à 96 87
pour sa régularité ça c'est la
technologie qui l'amène il n'y a pas de
mystère à équipements constant il n'y a
pas de miracle et même on en fait
quelquefois des miracles savais que mon
collègue suisse qui lui est super équipe
et ceux qui sont voisins de la suisse le
sable ça bien a dit publiquement que je
vous invite à le répéter c'est un peu
flatteur pour la sncf donc je le
situerais il dit même qu'il était
admiratif du niveau de performance que
nous avons en france compte tenu de
niveau des équipements qu'on avait
comparé aux suisses voyez donc voilà il
faut quand même dire les choses aussi
faux faux faux faux bien percevoir sa
donc à la fiabilité il ya un second
sujet de la modernité szélesi alors si
je pense que je suis quelle joie quel
est mon sensibilité européenne mais je
pense qu'elle est assez largement
partagé on est en train de devenir le
mauvais élève de l'europe l'europe du
ferroviaire se construit elle se
construit avec un système sinisation
unique pour que les trains puissent
passer facilement d'un pays à l'autre ça
s'appelle le ertms nous sommes en train
de prendre un retard très important
faute de moyens ces prêts peuvent lui
être que les autres on est capable de
déployer mais faute de moyens on le fait
pas on le fait très longuement et moi
j'ai une carte qui m'a beaucoup marqué
vous savez les cartes parfois ça marche
mais en tout cas ça marque qui projette
l'état du réseau européen 2040 par
rapport à cet équipement de six nations
européennes c'est vers la couleur de la
signal qui a été choisie tout est vert
sorte de deux points blancs le premier
c'est la lituanie par trop rares
lituanie s'est coincé en haut entre la
russie et les pays baltes bon c'est pas
très grave le second c'est nous c'est à
dire qu'on est en train de devenir le
mauvais élève de l'europe imaginez un
très équipés de rtms car il y aura des
pays bas de belgique il arrive à la
frontière ils veulent l espagne en
italie n'est pas passé en france
fait désordre quand même quand on a un
discours très européen de développement
européen ouverture européenne etc on a
un petit problème là encore de cohérence
technologique où ça serait quand même
dommage qu'on soit ceux qui sont en
retard pour assurer 7,7 ce nouvel élan
européen du ferroviaire
troisièmement c'est là j'arrive
maintenant peut-être plus au service
parce qu'effectivement le président l'a
dit pour que les clients voyageurs ou
des marchandises les oublions pas à
vienne autre info qui du service ils
vont pas venir parce qu'on les oblige
bon venir parce qu'ils ont envie il ya
trois sujets le premier alors celui-là
est huitième j'aime beaucoup je pense
que je sais ce qu'on appelle les réseaux
express métropolitains je pense que vous
êtes tous élus de territoire il ya
souvent une capitale régionale ya
toujours une capitale régionale à vos
territoires elle s'appelle marseille
elle s'appelle bordeaux il s'appelle
toulouse elle s'appelle nancy strasbourg
etc ça m'étonnerait que cevital spa
congestionné tous les matins et la
voiture d'ailleurs au niveau un peu les
traces du phénomène gilet jaune à ces
gens qui sont obligés de prendre leur
voiture qui habite à 30 35 kilomètres de
leur emploi qui met une heure une heure
et demie tous les matins de bouchons
pour entrer dans les villes ça leur
coûte du temps de la fatigue de l'argent
surtout quand le carburant est entre
oscille entre noro 50 et 2 euros dz et
feu qui vont rencontrer qui vont
peut-être voilà qui ont des parkings
comment est-ce qu'on se gare etc etc etc
mais pourquoi ils font ça faut pas sa
part gaieté de coeur il faut ça parce
qu'ils n'ont pas d'autres choix dont
faut être capable de leur offrir des
alternatives l'alternative elle existe
ça s'appelle les réseaux express
métropolitains en gros si on fait simple
du client un train tous les quarts
d'heure si au départ des villes qui sont
à 20 30 40 kilomètres des métropoles
régionales parce qu'elle est étoile
ferroviaire on est capables tous les
matins tous les soirs de mai des trains
au quart d'heure je suis convaincu que
les gens prendra peut-être leur voiture
parce qu'ils habitent dans un village à
la campagne la gare auront la première
gare utile sur un parking et prendre le
train pour rentrer centre-ville ils
gagneront du temps ils gagneront de
l'argent parce qu'il faut reconnaître
que les tarifications régionales sont
sûres sont raisonnables en matière de
prix rajoutons que pour les salariés
vous le savez les employeurs fait la
moitié donc au fond ça revient à presque
noro le voyage pour l'épauler pour les
voyageurs ça n'a rien à voir avec le
coût de la voiture rien à voir c'est une
mesure de pouvoir d'achat c'est une
mesure d'aménagement du territoire c'est
une mesure écologique c'est une mesure
énergétique elle a des qualités c'est en
gros un milliard et quelque part projet
en moyenne c'est accessible il y aurait
des tours de table possible suis
convaincu que les régions virer au tour
de table les présidents métropole vient
le tour de table voilà si le truc qu'il
faut ne pas faire ça ça serait quand
même passé à côté de quelque chose
deuxième sujet c'est le fret il avait
deux camps dans le frais de ce qu'il
croit d'au moins ceux qui croient plus
on peut les revenus du fret je peux le
comprendre tellement l'histoire du fret
a été compliqué dans ce pays depuis des
décennies bon moi j'y crois encore
d'abord par conviction je veux pas
laisser tout aux camions fait c'est
quand même pas possible qu'on laisse
tout aux camions voilà deux je rappelle
que le camion c'est pas demain la veille
qu'il sera vers 10hoo être clair il faut
pas croire aux sirènes qu'on vous
raconte il ya même pas un prototype de
camions hydrogène pour vous dire et
lille reviennent faudra le fabriquer
verts etc et pas cher voilà dans
l'histoire elle est longue elle se fera
peut-être jours mais les longues en
attendant elle très huilé là le trait il
a dont il fait c'est vraiment et je
rappelle le rappelle les chiffres une
tonnes transportées par train c'est en
gros 10 fois moins de co2 qu'une tonne
transportée par camion et l'énergie
parce que la sobriété est arrivée une
tonnes transportées par train coûte six
fois moins d'énergie qu'une tonne
transportée par camion pourquoi c'est le
frottement le frottement un train c'est
une roue en faire c'est en raillant
faire ça frotte pas une fois que la
masse est ébranlée hop il avance tout
seul le viol a rossé le pneu sur le
goudron bay frotte sinon la voiture elle
plombe le gamin il pas n'importe où ce
coefficient de frottement c'est quand
même incroyable c'est six fois moins
d'énergie et les ans le enjeux
écologiques en jeu sobriété énergétique
en fait donc ça vaut le coup de s'en
occuper peut pas laisser filer
d'affaires alors comment on fait pour
certains occupent et pourquoi ça
marchera ce coup ci alors que ça marche
pas depuis trente ans la question vaut
faut faire deux choses qu'on n'a pas
fait depuis 30 ans la première c'est des
infrastructures pour le fret le ferais
peut plus passer là il ya des
entreprises on voit bien en europe 1 a
repris trois points de parts de marché
l'année dernière s'est jamais vu depuis
30 ans pour la première fois depuis 30
ans voire 40 ans il ya un petit rebond
de l'activité du fret ferroviaire dans
notre pays super bon et pourquoi parce
que les entreprises est pourquoi ils
veulent faire du fret parce qu'elles
sont prises entre guillemets dans les
obligations de scope 3 vous savez de
verdissement leur approvisionnement qui
sont des contraintes qui pèsent de plus
en plus sur les entreprises est tant
mieux elle pense à quoi veut dire mon
les approvisionnements gelé pas sur le
train comme ça je vais moins polluer
encore faut-il qu'on puisse le faire
aujourd'hui on est bridée par les trois
structures donc c'est aussi pour ça
qu'il faut mettre un minimum de
programmes à faire le minimum minimorum
ses 2,3 milliards d'euros sur les
triages sur quelques évitement sur
l'accès au port c'est quand même
incroyable en 2022 on n'a toujours pas d
accès au port satisfaisant pas marseille
au havre on n'a pas des arrières port
bien desservies par train c'est pas tout
d'amener les containers qu'est-ce qu'on
en fait sinon on engorge les ports dans
faut il faut débarrasser les ports des
containers de faux des arrières ports
etc etc donc voilà ça c'est 2,3
milliards d'aud folie m folie m c'est
pas possible de parler m et puis
deuxièmement ça suffit toujours pas
parce qu'au fil du regarder encore tant
mieux pour eux le 46 tonnes à l'essieu
c'est à nouveau un avant d'un
désavantage compétitif par rapport au
train l'air de rien tant mieux pour la
route tant pis pour le train à dire
qu'on voit bien qu'au fur et à mesure la
route n'en finit pas d'avoir des
avantages compétitifs et donc au
détriment du train donc il ya bien
rééquilibrage de la situation
concurrentielle qu'il faut opérer il ya
deux manières de le faire ou on fait
payer pour lui à payeur où on aide le
train on peut être mille idées ne vois
là mais si on fait pas en plus ce
n'accompagne pas l'effort
d'infrastructures de du d'un juste
rééquilibrage juste jus équitable de
rééquilibrage équitable entre les modes
forcément on n'aidera pas je vous dis ça
parce que les pays qui l'ont fait ça
marche encore faisant du benchmark
européens à ne pas voir l'asie ou les
états unis en europe mais les bons
élèves y en a là où notre part de marché
et 1 9% ils sont à plus de 30%
l'autriche la suisse l'allemagne et à 25
les pays bas 25 donc c'est possible faux
faux faux pas croire ceux qui disent que
c'est pas possible c'est possible de
vous faire ce qu'il faut aller vers ce
but parce qu'il volera pas c'est assez
simple troisièmement les lignes à grande
vitesse
là encore moi je je suis un enfant la
grande vitesse - tous les sens du terme
me souviens de paris bordeaux en train
corail puis après j'ai vu le tgv
atlantique arrivée au paris pau bon
moi je crois à la grande vitesse quand
je suis conscient que ça coûte de
l'argent un projet à grande vitesse un
projet coûteux c'est vrai ça il faut pas
échapper à la question mais c'est un
projet qui rapporte la lgv elle c'est un
formidable accélérateur de pib dans tous
les territoires où les guînes à grand
vitesse de déconstruite on a vu la
dynamique économique exposés c'est une
loi générale en alsace en bretagne dans
le nord lille s'est sauvée grâce au tgv
lille était en plein déclin on est
d'accord les zélateurs du nord lille
était en plein déclin
du pas de calais
non je sais faire la différence pas de
calais voilà bel effet tgv il est
évident il est évident les faits étaient
d'ailleurs les territoires le demande
c'est isola dont jouit je pense qu'il
faut pas il faut pas renoncer j'allais
dire à compléter l'équipement de gvt et
notre pays alors vous serez pas surpris
qu'on aime mes origines moi je vois bien
la balade sujet elle me plaît beaucoup
bordeaux toulouse montpellier marseille
et jusqu'à la côte d'azur est branché
sur l'espagne branchies sur l'italie je
pense qu à l'évidence est facteur de pib
créer plus values foncières
j'ai fait un petit calcul la plus-value
foncière de la de l'agglomération de
marseille 30 % j'ai pris que 30% saas ou
je me trompe 16 pouces et plus ça
équivaut à la moitié du coût
d'investissement la ligne nouvelle entre
lyon et marseille donc c'est
considérable les plus values foncières
le problème c'est que ça revient pas aux
transports on n'a toujours pas trouvé le
système fiscal pour aller prendre une
petite partie cela et j'ai payé un peu
réussi voilà donc ce modèle intéressant
faut regarder un peu les gp parce que ça
donne un peu d idées sur comment on peut
capter un petit bout un petit bout de
plus value pour là pour le faire revenir
aux transports voilà ça c'est le x 2
après peut-être pour on passe aux
questions voilà et bien on passe aux
questions
ok merci monsieur le président je vais
regrouper les questions je vais donner
la parole à philippe tabarot on va
reprendre quatre questions et puis après
le présent répondre à une série de
quatre questions parce que j'ai j'ai
douze demandes d'intervention merci
président georges merci président
farandou j'avais deux millions de
questions à vous poser
vous avez répondu à une grande partie de
ces questions et puis on est en mode
sobriété c'est le mot à la mode de rue
est sobre également le nombre de
questions alors j'aurais aimé qu'on
détails mais vous ferez peut-être en
répandre à d'autres collègues la
question de la stratégie du groupe vous
l'avez évoqué vente rachat notamment en
terme de logistique qui est un vrai
grand sujet dans les questions je vais
pas vous parler du peu d'appétence des
joueurs du paris saint germain pour les
transports pour certains transports en
commun vous êtes exprimés ou en tout cas
vos vos collègues sur ce sujet ni de la
demande pour le moins saugrenue du
gouvernement qui demande à la sobriété à
au mode de transport le plus décarbonée
dans ce tumulte je note que le recours
train devient de plus en plus prégnant
naturellement ça signal positif que nous
plébiscitons ici dans cette commission
je rappelle que cette commission a
proposé fait voter la baisse de la tva à
5,5 pour le tra le doublement du fret
ferroviaire que vous avez évoqué est
encore un travail sur la baisse des
taxes
pour la sncf qui a été au final adopté
par l'assemblée nationale à notre notre
pression que ce soit pour la cst ou
l'attrait font qu'on essaie bien ces
sujets donc après un bel été teintée de
records de trafic vous devriez être
porté par un vent d'optimisme puissante
alors vous l'êtes de nature on l'a bien
compris mais cet intermède estival ne
peut occulter les difficultés
structurelles
qui vont obérer la dynamique du train si
elles ne sont pas affrontés une fois
pour toutes les sujets sont
malheureusement nombreux vous les avez
évoqué rapidement le coût de l'énergie
qui change la donne le poids financier
de la perfusion publique des
contribuables les problèmes de personnel
et de recrutement et le mouvement social
annoncé pour trois petits pois
mais je reste concentrée pour ma part
sur notre fil rouge l'âme et le
président longeole a rappelé la mauvaise
surprise du contrat de performance signé
entre sncf réseau et l'état document
stratégique signée à l'ombre de la
présidentielle est clairement de sa des
sommes nécessaires vous l'avait dit pour
moderniser améliorer notre réseau
aujourd'hui ce contrat multiplie les
renoncements prévoit des investissements
de renouvellement totalement insuffisant
fait l'impasse sur la modernisation
sanctuary zh la fragilité du réseau nous
avons été rejoints ce que nous avons été
les premiers à dénoncer sur cette
unanimité de constat et de combat depuis
par l'afld note la fra 4 f régions de
france et même le gendarme du rail la rt
qui a pointé ici même ce problème depuis
vous avez réagi de manière puissante
affirmé et courageuse en annonçant le
besoin d'investissements à 100 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires sur 15 ans afin
de contribuer à la décarbonation des
transports et en doublant la part du
train vous l'avez rappelé au même moment
faisant du belge parc également
l'allemagne vient d'annoncer un plan de
86 milliards l'italie un plan de 120
milliards sur les infrastructures pour
notre part est dans une logique
transpartisane nous avons passé notre
été
à évoquer ce sujet on a fait d'autres
choses aussi par arrêté mon a été
nombreux à évoquer ce sujet nous avons
déposé respect nous avons déposées
respectivement 7 et est un amendement
d'appel un cri d'alarmé avant le vrai
rendez vous de l'automne du plf en
demandant en défendant un rajout d'un
milliard sur le plfr 2022 cette idée
fait consensus au delà des clivages nous
avons retiré
lors de la discussion parlementaire je
peux vous dire que ce ne sera pas le cas
lors du plf nous combattons pour une
modernisation du rail mais pas une
modernisation rabais nous nous opposons
la version du gouvernement qui à travers
la bouche de gabriélat talent me
répondait de manière jupitérienne que
tous les moyens avaient été à la hauteur
lors du précédent mandat il ya une seule
vérité monsieur le président sans un
engagement financier beaucoup plus
massive de l'état vous le savez vous
l'avais dit à maintes fois le réseau
français va irrémédiablement décroché de
ses homologues européens aussi trois
petites questions un sursaut est il
encore possible avez vous reçu des
garanties du gouvernement que la copie
soit revue à la hausse pour une
amélioration nette de la mobilité
ferroviaire et si rien ne bouge et là
aussi vous avez un peu évoqué le sujet
avec beaucoup de prudence et on comprend
2 pensez vous pas que cela le ram ou
acterait une véritable mise en danger
des usagers du service comme le
présenter l'établissement fonds public
de sécurité ferroviaire
merci chers collègues je vais donner la
parole d'un policier du cul
si bien président vous fait plaisir à
entendre
vous président philippe tabarot à
l'instant et vous jean pierre farandou
on sent une véritable conviction
n'hésite pas à régler sur mon choix de
vie à trois hommes
ont longtemps d'accord alors j'ai
seulement
un million de questions alors j'ai
déposé cet été deux propositions de loi
la première le 31 août sur la tva à 5,5
si elle devait passer je n'en ai pas
trop de doute puisque le sénat l'a déjà
voté philippe l'a rappelé notamment dans
la loi climat résilience excellemment
rapportés par philippe vous engagez vous
véritablement répercuter intégralement
cette baisse de prix une question
précise la seconde ppl que j'ai posée
est relative aux contrats de performance
un article complémentaire de celle de
philippe tabarot qui se consomme sur le
fret j'ajoute un certain nombre de
critères pour sa rédaction il y à
unanimité pour dire que le contrat
actuel est catastrophique je tiens à
signaler la présence d'une carte
exclusive dans cette proposition de loi
qui démontre les ce que sont les é u
c'est les ulis et 5 à 6 les treize mille
kilomètres de réseau structurant qui
selon la rt pourrait se dégrader dans
les dix ans de ce contrat de performance
effrayant que pensez vous de l'idée
d'une véritable loi de programmation
pluriannuelle sur le ferroviaire si on
ne parvient pas à rattrapage dans le pl
deuxième question précise j'avais très
habile très agréablement accueilli votre
expression depuis la présidentielle sur
le x 2 sur les 100 milliards
philippe l'a qualifié de courageuse jeu
je le trouve aussi ouais mais où en
êtes-vous des engagements notamment
européens et gouvernementaux pour
garantir ce plan j'ai entendu le
ministre des transports sur france inter
fin juillet vous répondre que nous
sommes déjà sur la trajectoire
sous-entendu que je ne bougerai pas des
masses quoi il n'a pas l'air d'avoir
gagné ces arbitrages avec bercy
d'ailleurs c'est dommage j'en doute mais
je poserai la question dans 15 jours
mais encore comment dépenser cet argent
et qui a des contrats de performance
actuel pour vous aider l'article 2 de ma
ppl vise à supprimer la règle d'or
introduit par la loi de 2018 qui je la
firme n'est pas compatible avec le
schéma national bas carbone raison de
cet été m enfin
des petites questions au moment du
rapport spinetta je suis pas si vous en
rappeler c'était juste avant un nouveau
pacte ferroviaire on avait un premier
ministre qui s'appelait edouard philippe
qui se faisait fort d'avoir la tête des
cheminots et du statut des cheminots
c'est privilégier et je supprime des
calligraphes qualificatif presque
insultant à leur égard or libération
révélait hier que pour la première fois
vous contractualiser avec une entreprise
privée pour la formation des conducteurs
au delà de l'image dégradée que cela
peut procurer à l'entreprise je
m'inquiète du manque croissant du nombre
de conducteurs le chiffre de 12 mille a
tourné cet été qu'en est il combien de
trains supprimés comment allez-vous
résoudre ce problème particulièrement
dans certaines régions dont la mienne je
termine
alors là je suis beaucoup moins
satisfait parce que sncf l'institution
vous représentez a menti si si ma région
en supprimant une liaison directe nancy
lyon il y a quelques années sous
prétexte de travaux à lyon part dieu
bien entendu il serait rétabli alors je
crois que les travaux sont achevés vous
avez pourtant profité du coc vide pour
supprimer l'alternative qui avait été
mise en place par marne-la-vallée dans
des conditions assez satisfaisante et
qui améliorer les temps de transport
maintenant que les travaux sont terminés
qu'en est il du rétablissement le
rapport que nous avions obtenus sur
l'été a prouvé qu'il y avait un vrai
besoin sur cet axe entre les sillon
lorrain et rhénan et
petites questions complémentaires sur le
déploiement de 8 go à petite vitesse
pouvez vous nous faire des observations
là dessus le train léger autonome vous
avez beaucoup parler d'innovation
est ce qu'il pourrait reconsidérer
l'équation des petites lignes françaises
et puis une toute dernière qui vient de
me venir en écoutant philippe grâce au
sénat je crois philippe et la loi climat
très prochainement genre tu t'énerves
annoncé le transfert de l'autoroute a31
à la région la mise en place d'une
écotaxe poids lourd qui pourrait être
une première nationale sur un axe
particulièrement saturé il se trouve que
cette autoroute a31 est doublée d'une
des trois quatre autoroutes ferroviaires
françaises l'âme et hambourg perpignan
ne pourrait-on imaginer des
expérimentations pour venir en appui de
ce transfert de la mise en place d'une
première éco taxe sur l'a31 qui sera un
laboratoire national je vous remercie
beaucoup de patience et si chers
collègues je donne la parole à didier
montet dit oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur présent vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure le poids de sncf
sur plan économique au niveau national
cela représentait moi j'ai une question
en lien avec le projet de loi qui nous
arrive sur les énergies renouvelables
pas en lien direct avec le contrat de
performance mais vous l'avez dit vous
êtes un acteur important qui dispose
d'un foncier très important et dans le
texte qui nous est présentée ou qui ne
sera présenté la semaine prochaine il
est prévu un ensemble de dispositions
pour que sur les délaissés autoroutier
sur un surnombre de sites on puisse
faciliter l'implantation notamment de
photovoltaïque est ce que alors je sais
que sncf est engagée déjà sur sur le
sujet est-ce que vous avez une idée du
potentiel qui pourrait être utilisé pour
cet usage et est-ce que cela
nécessiterait des ajustements
législatifs
qui pourraient être prises en compte
dans le cadre de ce projet de loi
puisque rien n'y figure à ce stade
merci je vais laisser la parole c'est un
directeur général
ok peut-être sur la sur la sobriété
effectivement donc
je pense qu'il faut distinguer sobriété
rationnement on et sobriété c'est faire
la même chose avec moins d'énergie c'est
pas faire moins de choses on verra donc
en tout cas c'est comme ça que je
conçois on a été saisie comme toutes les
entreprises par le gouvernement on
pourrait être capable de faire moins 10%
par la sobriété d'ici deux ans on a
répondu qu'on saurait faire
comment on fait il ya le tertiaire et
puis il ya la traction des trains sur le
tertiaire bah si les gestes simples
d'économie un combat auquel on peut tous
penser qu'on peut pousser un peu plus
loin
et ça peut rapporter 1 c'est
l'exemplarité et c'est donc ça on va le
faire bien évidemment on a commencé
c'est aussi peut-être de
l'investissement parce que c'est pour ça
qu'il faut au moins deux ans parce que
tout ce qu'ils lisent aux relations
bâtiment ça se fait pas du jour au
lendemain donc on est tout à fait prêt à
accélérer un plan de notamment sur les
bâtiments pour mieux isoler les
bâtiments etc etc donc ça on va le faire
et sur l'aspect conduite on n'est pas
dans une logique de suppressions de
trains dans le plan de sobriété que ce
soit très clair je crois que c'était
confirmé par le ministre il ya eu un peu
de confusion sur le sujet on peut faire
l'idée de ralentir les trains et paris
sympathique mais ça marche pas parce
qu'on voit si on chez l'ouest quand on
le fait ça avec toutes les
correspondances en l'air sur l' axe pour
bordeaux paris dont imaginez si tous les
trains sont en retard on sait en sort
plus dans les correspondances
deuxièmement l'attractivité du train
baisse quand même donc on y de citer les
gens ne prend l'avion ou reprendre la
voiture et 3 la productivité des moyens
aussi parce que si vous aller plus
lentement la productivité à la fois des
mains des matériels roulants mais aussi
des conducteurs dans le même horaire et
on paie à l'horaire il faut au moins
deux kilomètres donc pour l'ensemble des
trois facteurs c'est pas une bonne idée
bon je crois que ça a été reconnue par
le gouvernement
voilà donc donc on fait l'éco-conduite
on le fait déjà mais on peut aller plus
loin plus fort en veillant à ce que les
conducteurs profite du profil en fait
assez comment quand ça descend on
n'accélère pas on est vite fait de
freiner d'accélérer inutilement on se
sert de ce fameux cette capacité du
train à rouler tout seul nous allons
optimiser au maximum pour consommer le
moins possible et ça peut rapporter
beaucoup ça peut l'aider très bon
conducteur arrive à gagner 10 à 15 %
n'en faut que faut qu'un conducteur
moyen y arrive voilà ce que le très bon
c'est faire parce que voilà il a de
l'expérience il faut absolument propagez
cette expérience le plus largement
possible parce que tous les conducteurs
sont capables de le faire on avait aussi
des pratiques qui fort qu'il faut
considérer à l'époque où les nages et et
pas cher on pouvait laisser à l'arrêt ce
qu'on appelle l'écho stationnement en
stationnement ont laissé les pentes au
lever pour assurer le chauffage de qui
mène sur machin pendant des heures et
des heures et des heures voire toute la
nuit bon ce genre de pratique va falloir
arrêter quitte à faire venir quelques
heures plus tôt pour une heure plus tôt
roche-aux-fées la ram etc voilà on a
quelques économies accessible en
revoyant nos mois d'organisation et
quand on combine tout ça on doit être en
doit être aux 10% voilà
[Musique]
le benchmark vous l'avez dit
alors
vous avez raison en fait je sais aussi
une
idée objective que j'ai moi je voudrais
il faut pas opposer les deux idées il ya
l'idée de dse plf avoir milliards de
plus sur le réseau ne serait-ce pour
rattraper les surcoûts parce que pas de
bol voilà alors mais vous vous le voyez
aussi dans toutes les collectivités et
les travaux coûtent plus cher t.ac.a le
même argent comme ça a pris 10 ou 15% le
béton
l'acier les salaires et compagnie avec
le même argent on fait 10 à 15% de moins
bon c'est pas l'idée de faire moins bon
donc faut déjà rattrapé le surcoût
inflation
voilà les quelques centaines de millions
d'euros à la clé et si possible marquer
la volonté du gouvernement pas voilà un
acte fort qui montre que oui on commence
à engager dès 2023 cette volonté forte
de redresser l'état du réseau ça c'est
un don les ja m'bia bien le premier
sujet des le ps 23 exactement qui est
pas très loin devant de grandeur que
vous avez cités voilà pour moi ça ne
s'oppose pas et je suis très favorable
question m'a été posée à une véritable
loi de programmation parce que pour
éviter justement ce stress ou année
après année budget après budget on sait
pas trop ce qui va se passer et il faut
du temps long pour faire ça donc le
temps long la traduction législative du
temps long ses doigts programmation il
faut une loi de programmation sur dix en
plus si on peu moins de 10 ans qui va à
partir d'une ambition fixée diab et
voilà donc ce qu'il faut faire notamment
sur l'infrastructure et donc voilà les
moyens qu'il faut dégager pour y arriver
on a là aussi besoin de produits
industriels pour pour recruter par
exemple des ingénieurs il faut être sûr
qu'ils ont du boulot pour dix ans si on
n'est pas sûr ben on est toujours embêté
de dire on le recrute on recrute pas on
fait quoi pareil pour les pour les pour
les vététistes a qui vont peut-être
acheter des machines supplémentaires
pour changer les rails ça coûterait cher
des machines comme ça si l'on dix ans de
boulot devant eux ils feront les
investissements s'ils sont pas sûrs
belfond pas pareil pour l'industrie
ferroviaire etc et c'est donc une loi de
programmation on est à la fois
nécessaire pour concrétiser l'ambition
pour de vrai mais il est aussi
nécessaire pour organiser l'industrie
autour de ça et recruté il ya un effet
emploi est évident qu'ils étaient
derrière donc oui je suis très favorable
mais c'est les deux ouais moi je
voudrais qu'on puisse faire les deux à
la fois marquer dès cette année une
inflexion positive autour de la
régénération du réseau et puis s'engager
alors ça prendra plus de temps mais qui
est un vrai travail de co-construction
d'ailleurs avec la représentation
nationale sur une loi de programmation
pluriannuelle cctv nativement
l'instrument dont on a besoin les
benchmark ou les cité c'est qu'ils
confirment que les autres grands pays
européens mettent le paquet sur le
ferroviaire voilà donc ça serait un peu
curieux que nous on se laisse décalé et
voyez donc et donc qu'il faut le faire
sur la tv à la question posée
je vais me remettre avec vous parce que
vous savez que j'aime bien l'être si je
dois classer les priorités je préfère
que l'argent public qui lie à
l'investissement voilà ce que j'ai dit
avant apprécié année un peu plus et sont
peu allégé la fiscalité pour les avions
on le fera voilà bien évidemment si 7,7
des mains si cette décision devait
intervenir on jouera le jeu puisque
c'est son objectif son objectif c'est
que ça coûte moins cher à l'usagé donc
voila mais je le redis ma première
priorité c'est quand même mobiliser
l'argent public pour l'infrastructure
pour l'investissement
tout tout tout
alors les problèmes de recrutement etc
ils sont vraies on va pas le nier d'or
vous le voyez de 6,2 l'année alors il
faut les quantifier il nous manque
important de conducteurs leleu 12000
c'est le nombre de conducteurs à peu
près il ne loue pas 2000 conducteur il
nous manque un pour cent de ses 12 me
bon ça fait 120 bon alors après 120
conducteur il manque quand il en a qui
manque ça fait d'être est supprimée et
ça c'est sûr que les faits et direct bon
alors déjà c'est pas massif mais quand
même l'explication principale c'est que
on a mal anticipé le fait que pendant le
coc vie forcément les écoles n'ont pas
fonctionné parce qu'on ne pouvait pas
mettre déjà ensemble et on n'avait pas
mis au point les méthodes pédagogiques
pour but d'informer un conducteur à 10
ans et des limites qu importe ça
commence à être compliqué de former un
conducteur de train par team sky ça
commence à être compliquée bon donc on
les a pas formés et on a pris un retard
et comme il faut un an pour former un
conducteur vous on encaisse en ce moment
on est en train de rattraper le retard
voilà mais en attendant il ya delta et
s'explique alors je sais bien que ça
peut paraître surprenant pour pour
vraiment faire feu de tout bois et et
accélérer au maximum l'effort de
formation et un peu en dernier recours
on a fait appel à une école de formation
privés alors c'est très exceptionnel
mais ça vous montre que voilà parce que
sinon on va mobiliser des formateurs des
formateurs de l'abonné pour conduire les
trains dont 49
on a c'est peut-être c'est par
dérogation et par exception on a éprouvé
le besoin d'aller renforcer au maximum
notre appareil de formation en recourant
à une école extérieurs à la sncf
tout tout tout sur le nancy lyon bon
nancy lyon
ça rend alors il ya un avant après la
loi fait j'y reviens je vais me dis dans
mon introduction c'est parfois compliqué
à comprendre pour les territoires je
peux le comprendre
si on fait une incision ans craignent de
perdre de l'argent et ça va nous manger
une rame
c'est ramon n'aura pas pour faire autre
chose pas de mystère on vous savez qu'en
soit andy ram on en manque un peu mais
on n'est pas très à l'aise et on a même
eu un bien plus grand et on a le
sentiment peut-être nous trompons nous
mais c'est notre responsabilité que ce
train serait pas équilibré voilà c'est
la raison fondamentale dans notre rôle
sociétés anonymes tels que la loi l'a
voulu on est obligé de faire cette
réponse à un territoire j'ai bien
qu'elle ait pas satisfaisante mais c'est
ça la logique intrinsèque que cette
réforme a déclenché après on peut
observer refaire d'études de marché etc
etc si un regain du train on sera ravi
de de le faire
je voudrais aussi peut-être parce que
c'est important de ne pas opposer les
choses et en tout cas dans la place je
me suis de président du bois de public
vous dire comment contrat de performance
vous l'avez vous l'avez vous avez vous
l'avez apprécié vous l'avait évalué
moi je lui donnerai une porte de sortie
cette porte de sortie ces notions de
l'acteur acte 2 honnêtement ce contrat
performance en a mis deux ans à le à le
conclure ce qui est long et donc cette
espèce est un appendice de la loi 2018
et en 2018 honnêtement on n'était pas
dans le développement du ferroviaire
massif les zips les sous jacents du
ferroviaire c'était comme le pib de 1%
et demi de pourcentage il n'y avait pas
une volonté de croissance forte et donc
se contentent performance il rêve il est
cohérent avec ça à partir du moment où
on peut souhaiter tout ce qu'on s'en va
vers une ambition forte baisse et l'acte
ii est effectivement l'acte ii il
suppose une révision du contrat
performance voilà donc je pense que tout
cas c'est ma manière à moi de présenter
les choses qui permet d'articuler le
passé et l'avenir
est quand même aussi pour être honnête
quand même dire et rappeler que dans le
plan de relance on a eu quand même 4
milliards 7 pour rénover le réseau donc
voilà je pense qu'il faut aussi être
globale dans l'appréciation de qu'est ce
qui a pu se faire sur le ferroviaire c
est cédé à ces dernières années
traîne et qui luttaient eux
sur le we go train train classique ça
marche bien ça marche bien ça ça fait
revenir au train parce que c'est pas
cher c'est vraiment très simple c'est
vraiment une mesure pouvoir d'achat
avant que les crises pouvoir d'achat
n'interviennent que la décision était
prise avant ces des billets à 10 euros
15 euros 1 il ya des gens qui acceptent
de passer quatre heures pour faire un
paris nantes mais ne payer que 10 euros
15 euros voilà parce qu'ils n'ont pas
trop de sous et on voit des gens qui
quittent la voiture ou qui quitte le
quart pour prendre le train après tout
le monde est content ils sont dans le
train bon voila et et le remplissage est
correct on gagne notre vie pour qu
organe audi parce que ces leçons et
matériels amorti ses des vieux corail un
conte un peu relifté ils sont
complètement amortis donc il ya plus de
coûts de capital il était égale à zéro
bon on a que le coût marginal
d'exploitation du train bondé et donc au
fond c'est une mesure pouvoir d'achat
qui me semble utile et intéressante les
trains légers oui vous avez raison de me
lancer là dessus j'ai oublié de le dire
j'avais tellement de choses à vous dire
merci de nous donner l'occasion il faut
que alors et j'y suis pas comme un
étranger quand même je veux que la sncf
s'intéresse aussi aux territoires diffus
la sncf s'est pas que les grandes villes
c'est pas que les oies c'est aussi une
réponse ferroviaire au territoire du fus
pas quand cette réponse et doit être
adapté c'est pas le très lourd qui coûte
cher et c'est si l'on n'y arrive pas
économiquement donc oui nous sommes en
innovation et par exemple il ya le
prototype existe on peut le voir il
marche c'est un engin qui est mimi mille
karmitz il a des pneus comme il a des
pneus il se transforme en quarts en
minicar pour une vingtaine de personnes
il va chercher les gens dans des hameaux
et puis quand il arrive sur un passage à
niveau il s'enraye il devient très beau
fils mais sur le rail et le cra qui
devient train il pour sortir ou pas 20
ou 30 km plus tard ça ce sont des
techniques qui sont parfaitement adaptés
à une commis à une desserte comines et
routières ferroviaires des territoires
diffus et qui pourraient trouver leur
place dans une stratégie régionale pour
aller justement apporter une réponse et
on voit bien que ça coûte pas trop cher
des engins coûte pas trop cher parce
qu'on vient la voiture qui a rien à voir
avec le train on est sur des petites
lignes du coup les vitesses peuvent être
ajustés donc on a moins besoin de mettre
beaucoup d'argent dans l'infrastructure
on voit que oui on commence à avoir des
réponses combiné ferroviaire pour
desservir ces petits territoires
sur les autoroutes c'est une bonne piste
est là puisque vous évoquez
il faut réfléchir on sait que les
concessions autoroutières arriva interne
un jour
est-ce qu'il faut pas regarder comment
dans ce cadre on peut trouver des
combinaisons entre le monde autoroutier
le mode ferroviaire pour assurer au fond
une
revenus pérennes à l'entretien du
ferroviaire en partie en tout cas je
crois c'est une piste qu'il faut
commencer à regarder dans toute
expérimentation qui va dans ce sens me
paraît pertinente enfin merci pour la
question posée parce que je voulais
aussi en parler
j'ai dit sncf acteurs majeurs la
transition écologique assure la mobilité
on en a beaucoup parlé mais on peut
aussi être un acteur majeur en
produisons nous-mêmes d'électricité
verte on y travaille on y travaille
merci nous alerter d'ailleurs que dans
le projet de loi il ya peut-être des
compléments apportés parce que moi j'en
ai besoin les potentiels sont sont
énormes mais pas toujours facilement
accessibles en fait seule la sncf vous
savez que c'est le second propriétaire
foncier de france on a cent mille
hectares alors les hectares ont pas tous
la même tête les hectares les plus
faciles à équiper sont des experts comme
des idées anciennes cours marchandise
volée des espaces parce que là les
panneaux solaires à cellules cellules
solaires les panneaux solaires ils sont
un peu carré ou rectangulaire encore il
dessine des trucs comme ça dans les
espaces qui correspondent on voit on les
toits les ateliers etc on voit donc ça
on a en un potentiel significatif qui
pourrait être équipée assez vite virgule
vite si la loi le permet un des gros
enjeux de la loi là encore en prenant
exemple sur l'allemagne en allemagne et
l'allemagne c'est un pays vertueux du
point de vue écologique d'ailleurs il ya
une majorité où les écolos seront sur
gouvernement donc on peut pas soupçonner
les allemands d'être des anti écologique
primaires ce serait une mauvaise
appréciation de leur politique eh bien
les allemands ont dans leurs lois sur
les panneaux solaires fait en sorte
qu'on peut équiper en 18 mois
avec des panneaux solaires nous
aujourd'hui c'est cinq ou six ans parce
que parce qu'on connaît la france
procédure enquête contre enquête
appréciation évaluation etc etc
nous nous nous voudrions effectivement
qu avec le parlement et donc les
sénateurs et peut-être cette commission
on puisse regarder s'il ya pas une forme
de dérogation pour le pôle est délaissée
du ferroviaire les délices innovia vous
les connaissez c'est pas les endroits
les plus cordiales et les plus les plus
en vue des populations etc je pense que
ça poserait pas de gros problème
d'équipé massivement de panneaux
solaires les délaissés du ferroviaire
voilà donc voilà donc je pense
qu'effectivement merci de temps de cette
perche il ya une thèmes de travail que
nous voulons aborder avec vous et si
vous êtes d'accord effectivement on peut
travailler à la commission pour voir
comment on peut nous permettre d'aller
plus vite plus fort et apporter une
réponse énergétique aux besoins du pays
mais merci je pense que la question
qu'ils ont été posées par l'ailier melun
délit n'était pas innocente
puisqu'ils ce sera bon j'anticipe mais
sur le vote de tout à l'heure mais sur
la loi sur les énergies renouvelables il
aura un rô le important et c'est
peut-être une opportunité à ce moment là
de fait quelques jours voilà
merci bonjour monsieur farandou et merci
d'être devant notre commission je
souhaite aborder trois points tout
d'abord en tant que sénateur de la somme
et et client habituel
de amiens paris et je vous remercie
d'avoir cité le mot client dans votre
propos ma première question portera donc
légitimement sur ce réseau de transport
régional ma région accuse en ce moment
et vous savez
environ 10% de suppressions de trains
par jour en raison du déficit de
conducteurs dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure
ce chiffre monte jusqu'à 50% dans
certains territoires aux français si en
moyenne 10% des trains ne partent pas
permettez moi d'être un peu provocateur
ne serait-il pas juste que les factures
des collectivités soient réduites de 10%
comment expliquer que les régions paix
pour des trains qui ne partent pas très
sérieusement ce problème de fiabilité
que nous rencontrons dans notre région
fait cassandre de clients risquent de se
détourner de ce moyen de transport moi
le premier quand j'ai un rendez vous
important au sénat j'ai pris la décision
de venir en voiture
la deuxième question concerne une
annonce de la sncf qui pour pallier la
potentielle pénurie d'énergie cet hiver
pourrait purement et simplement
supprimer certains trajets pendant
quelques mois et ce prochainement son
but il les usagers se prépare déjà au
déjà au pire alors que la sncf consomme
chaque jour en électricité m'a-t-on dit
vous pourrez peut-être me le confirmer
l'équivalent de la production d'un
réacteur nucléaire
doit-on craindre monsieur le président
une réduction d'activité des trains cet
hiver et si oui dans quelle ampleur
troisième et dernière question sur un
sujet beaucoup plus générale cette fois
celui de la lutte contre les incivilités
dans les trains musique offerte
gracieusement par des voyageurs sans
scrupules échanges téléphoniques dont
profite l'ensemble des voyageurs des
wagons crachats ou encore mégots de
cigarettes jetés sur lequel sont monnaie
courante et bénéficier d'une sorte d'
acceptation tacite et donc d'impunité
si je peux aisément comprendre la
crainte que peuvent ressentir les
contrôleurs à réprimer ces comportements
je suis persuadé que les laisser
prospérer est vraiment la porte ouverte
à des dérives bien plus grave je vous
invite d'ailleurs à faire le trajet
paris amiens à 16h04 pour vérifier mes
propos de ce président comment
aidez-vous garantir aux usagers du thé
vert un voyage plus serein et surtout un
voyage plus civique
si je vais donner la parole à bruno roux
jean
[Musique]
merci président de me de me donner la
parole monsieur farandou je ne résiste
pas avec votre présence ce matin vous
parlez territoire puisque vous avez dit
que vous aviez quatre axes qui était
très important et je vous parlais du
mien le département de l'allier
département de l'allier trois villes
moyennes vichy moulins et puis montluçon
on part souvent on a souvent parlé
effectivement des deux villes de vichy
et de moluçon parce que c'est la
desserte à partir de clermont ferrand on
connaît aujourd'hui les axes de travail
qui vont permettre et les orientations
futures qui vont permettre à cette ligne
toutes les améliorations que nous que
nous attendons donc en fait les
perspectives de vichy et de pollution
sont plutôt bonnes dans la liaison avec
paris mais il ya bien pire dans le
département de l'allier il ya montluçon
moluçon c'est la première ville en terme
de population et cette ville de
montluçon qui est au bout du bout là qui
finalement en espèces de terminus qui
n'a pas donc de grandes agglomérations
vers lequel se dirige le train est
complètement abandonné par sa avec sa
liaison avec avec paris vous n'imaginez
pas vous n'imaginez pas les difficultés
que sa peau c'est une ville industrielle
qui a de nombreux emplois en termes de
porteurs de projets quand on reçoit un
porteur de projet dans cette ville là et
que pour venir de de paris il va être
obligé de passer par bourges de changer
de train etc donc j'en ai déjà parlé
avec un certain nombre d'interlocuteurs
qui vous accompagnent ici pour cette
réunion de ce matin mais il y à vraiment
à faire quelque chose de particulier
pour moluçon quand j'étais jeune puisque
moi j'habite dans la rue montluçonnaise
je m'étais bien moins de temps je
m'étais 30 minutes de moins largement
pour prendre en prenant le train à
montluçon pour venir à paris voire même
40 minutes de moins donc les choses
n'ont fait que se détériorer alors
localement on essayé de réfléchir un peu
parce qu'on sait très bien que en fait
on peut par n'allait pas décréter du
jour au lendemain quelque chose et ce
que nous aimerions
c'est que puisque vous parlez de la
volonté des territoires qu'on met en
place à titre expérimental pour voir un
peu ce que ça donne alors j'ai
l'impression j'en parle depuis des mois
à certains des interlocuteurs de votre
de votre service mais je n'ai finalement
jamais de retour l'idée de tester un
train direct le matin moluçon paris est
un train direct le soir en semaine paris
moluçon ça nous permettrait de voir s'il
ya effectivement enfin un potentiel par
rapport à tout cela ça vous permettrait
vous de juger peut-être s'y lie à une
future une rentabilité possible par
rapport à cette affaire et pour j'allais
dire le monde économique de cette grande
région montluçonnaise et bien me
luçonnais ça serait vraiment la marque
de quelque chose de tenter quelque chose
que la sncf se préoccupe de cette
situation absolument dramatique voilà
l'intervention que je voulais faire
devant vous ce matin merci chers
collègues je vais donner la parole à
régler
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président directeur général j'ai envie
un peu de vous provoquer et de vous dire
à vouloir courir plusieurs lièvres à la
fois on n'arrive pas à destination
et donc vous mettez en étendard donc la
somme de 100 milliards d'euros sur
laquelle on aimerait avoir des
précisions puisque sur les 100 milliards
vous demanderiez 50 milliards à l'état
si j'ai bien compris donc comment vous
envisagez le financement des 50 autres
milliards mais c'est surtout la question
c'est comment on va financer globalement
l'ensemble des enjeux alors qu'on peut
considérer qu'aujourd'hui on est face à
un mur budgétaire et vous avez souligné
un certain nombre de ces enjeux
effectivement dans vos propos donc le
foie deux réseaux usage et transport du
quotidien et lgv vous pensez très
sérieusement qu'on va pouvoir dans les
années à venir tout faire tout financer
est ce qu'il n'ya pas aujourd'hui des
priorités évidentes pour éviter comme
vous l'avez très bien dit ce décrochage
par rapport à l'ensemble des réseaux
européens et ses priorités est ce que
vous pourriez nous les préciser est ce
que vous imaginez vraiment qu'on va
pouvoir courir tous les lièvres à la
fois et répondre à l'ensemble des
perspectives qui sont à l'heure actuelle
sur la table je les rappelle réseau
usage et transport du quotidien et
nouvelle lgv puisqu'il ya des nouvelles
gvt et qui sont prévues là dessus donc
vous mettez en avant la reconquête du
fret ferroviaire avec 9% de part modale
actuellement dont vous souhaitez
effectivement la double et vous indiquer
qu'il faudrait y consacrer à l'unim à 15
milliards d'euros en quinze ans est ce
que c'est bien ce chiffre vous pouvez
leur préciser peut-être n'est-ce pas la
priorité numéro un injustement avec les
transports du quotidien et les
améliorations du réseau et puis on
constate au niveau de l'offre de
services un certain nombre
d'interrogations et d'inquiétudes mes
collègues ont pu en faire part sur la
ligne bordeaux-paris on est passé de
18,5 liaison à 14 alors il y avait la
crise qu vite bien sûr mais l'offre de
service n'a pas été rétablie il me
semble à ce jour alors bien sûr il ya
une le phénomène saisonnier au niveau
des des congés des vacances mais est ce
que cette offre de service va être
établi de manière effectivement pérenne
sur cette offre et puis c'était souligné
on a une dégradation très fortes
notamment au niveau des pyrénées
atlantiques de la liaison avec pau faut
savoir qu'à certains moments on
n'arrivait même plus de pau à remonter
sur paris si on prenait le billet on
prenait pas le billet 15 jours à valence
c'était plus possible une vraie
dégradation
vous avez parlé effectivement de manque
de matériel aussi abandonné mais il
semble que pour ouvrir de nouveaux
marchés en espagne vous ayez envoyer
aussi du matériel en espagne qui nous
fait aussi un peu défaut aujourd'hui
donc est-ce que vous ne pourriez nous
donner des précisions sur le sujet enfin
dernier point sur l'offre tarifaire
l'application du yann management
c'est-à-dire la tarification en temps
réel en fonction de la demande fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a vu des écarts de
prix absolument considérables et ont
monté en seconde classe sur des tarifs
plus chers parfois qu'on première c'est
incroyable mais c'est vrai c'est qui ce
qui a pu se passer à certains moments
compte-tenu effectivement de la pression
qui pouvait y avoir alors il peut y
avoir évidemment un intérêt évident par
rapport aux finances de la sncf mais
vis-à-vis de l'offre de service en
direction des usagers ça pose quand même
des vraies questions sur le fond alors
vous mettez en avant des des nouvelles
liaisons avec des matériels adaptés par
rapport à des tarifs privilégiés on ne
peut être que d'accord avec vous par
rapport à ça mais on voit bien quand
même que derrière l'offre de service il
ya quand même un intérêt aussi
économique qui dégradent quelque part
aussi au niveau de l'offre tarifaire la
relation avec les usagers je vous
remercie merci j'ai ma parole à frédéric
marche merci monsieur le président
roseraie au président je suis à rendre
leur réponse monsieur le président
farandou vous avez évoqué dans vos
propos introductif votre feuille de
route et notamment j'ai noté la capacité
de la sncf à s'interfacer avec les
collectivités locales je ne vais pas
vous parler des autres france bien
évidemment je voudrais par contre vous
parler d'un sujet qui a été un peu
abordée par mon collègue didier mandelli
qui est effectivement celui des friches
puisque vous l'avez rappelé la sncf est
aujourd'hui le deuxième propriétaire
foncier de france et que les friches on
dans les années à venir un bel avenir
devant elle et notamment en lien étroit
avec les collectivités territoriales qui
à la recherche de foncier bien
évidemment sont intéressés par un
dialogue fécond et productif avec la
sncf alors ma question elle sera toute
simple est ce qu'il existe aujourd'hui
une cartographie précise de ces friches
et est ce qu'il existe au niveau de vos
services une stratégie nationale qui
permettrait effectivement en lien avec
les collectivités de réfléchir bien
évidemment sur la question de la
transition écologique mais aussi et
pourquoi pas sur la question du logement
mais aussi pourquoi pas sur la fameuse
question de l'alimentation qui revient
aujourd'hui au coeur de nombre de
préoccupations et il me semble que
certains délaissé de terrain pourrait
être utilisée notamment pour des
utilisations qui tourne autour de
l'alimentation merci
monsieur le président je vous propose de
répondre à mes collègues oui alors
c'est pas rien mais c'est sûr par msc
j'ai une pensée d'abord comme vous ce
que vous en faites partie d'ailleurs
pour les milliers d'usagers tous les
jours qui depuis des années on pas une
desserte très satisfaisante
il ya des causes intrinsèque et
il ya des causes un peu cochon turrel
qu'on peut et surtout qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire derrière et quand intrinsèque
c'est d'être un très dense s'est pas
remis des trains les plus denses de
france c'est ce qu'ils connaissent pas
assez les trains où il peut y avoir deux
mille personnes par train passer énorme
autres et parce qu'il ya énormément de
monde en fait qui habite dans la somme
dans l'oise aussi athlétique de loi ce
qui est beau c'est à paris tous les
jours énormément c'est peut-être
l'endroit où il ya le plus même dans le
grand bassin parisien bon voilà c'est un
choix de vie qui s'est fait prix prix de
paris prix de la somme c'est moins cher
on s'installe et ses bons et ses massifs
deuxièmement on a appris pour faire des
trains
il ya une desserte des matériels des
conducteurs bon
et on arrive quelque part alors à
commencer par ses renard il gare du nord
gare du nord elle est saturée donc le
moindre aléa fait boule de neige et ça
c'est une réalité 2 et ça c'est après on
a rendant d'édifices à jusqu'à la
voilà
c'est une réalité avec laquelle il faut
composer avec la région avec lequel
l'autorité organisatrice de ces trains
il ya trois sujets il ya la nature des
dessertes les dessertes nous on souhaite
que les desserts soit plus qu'à danser
régulière on a des missions différentes
dire que y'a un train à s'arrêter à une
gare mais celui d'après va pas s'arrêter
etc etc il ya des dessertes un peu
hétérogène héritière de l'histoire ça
nous rend la gestion opérationnelle très
compliqué parce qu'on part en place et
un train par un autre etc dont nous
pensons que même par rapport à la
robustesse technique de l'ensemble pour
des pouvoir travailler avec l'accord du
conseil régional sur une forme de
simplification des schémas de desserts
pour être plus robuste en production de
matériel roulant le matériel roulant il
commence à vieillir c'est encore des
locomotives tracts et ça fait penser
d'ailleurs à il ya d'autres endroits et
la locomotive tracts et ce à plus de 40
ans et la r16 une locomotive en 40 ans
les voitures en 40 ans les voitures les
wagons et aux voyageurs bon des engins
comme ça c'est ancien la politique de
parc elle relève de choix de la région
nature des matériels politique
industrielle de maintenance aussi ça
c'est des choix de la région donc on
discute avions fait des propositions
mais il est important aussi que des
actes forts soient posés ils le sont
mais enfin on voit bien que le sont les
investissements qui sont faits mais on
voit bien que tout retard qui a peut
être pris pour une rixe ou y forcément
c'est un moment qu'on a encore du mal à
rattraper en quantité de parc en nature
de parc en fiabilité de par trois les
conducteurs ça c'est pas la région c'est
nous qu'on s'est planté on s'est planté
plus lourdement en outre france
qu'ailleurs le fameux 1% en moyenne il
est plus proche d'eux oui plusieurs
pourcents en tout cas en août france
s'est planté on s'est planté le problème
comme dans ces plantes et voilà il faut
un presque deux ans pour se remettre
parce qu'il ya un an de retard on se
remet en branle on embauche énormément
on embauche énormément pour retrouver un
niveau de conducteurs mais en attendant
on a un problème il se fait d'ailleurs
après estafette alors il faut le
résoudre le plus rapidement possible et
revenir nominale plus loin possible mais
il ya un temps incompressible de
recrutement et de formation
4 l'aspect financier il est réglé par la
région elle-même ne vous a pas échappé
que
région a pris l'initiative unilatérale
pour apporter une réponse financière à 1
devant ce constat de difficultés la ccv
réaliser le service voilà on en discute
on peut la trouver la trouve un peu
excessif parfois l'enfant en tout cas il
ya une forme de régulation qui se fait à
venir voilà mais en tout cas sachez très
bien que dès lors je m'implique
personnellement sur le picard ni moi n'y
a pas invités à prendre le ceser 4
pourquoi pas je peux vous dire que je
sais pas il ya un mois deux mois je suis
bien parti la veille pour être aux
premières heures du matin j'ai fait
l'ouverture de la gare d'amiens à 5h30
du matin pour être pour être à portée de
baffes comme disent certains sap a loupé
un trait supprimer donc je me suis pris
des baffes dans le président sncf est
allé prendre cebaph à la gare d'amiens
ya rien de tel pour entendre les usagers
comprend leurs problèmes parce que même
si en train demi heure après c'est une
demi heure c'est beaucoup et c'est
accepter en plus le train quand tu pries
humains très insuffisants les gens sont
passés ils sont non seulement en retard
mais en plus ils voyagent moins
conditions etc etc ça mais les cheminots
dans une situation très compliquée ils
peuvent rien les cheminots de la gare
on le voit bien que ils sont en première
ligne par rapport aux usagers qui sont
mécontents et voilà donc je suis tout à
fait conscient ne serait ce parce que je
suis allé voir moi-même et vivre au
moins même que c'est une situation
difficile ce que j'appelle ce que au
fond devant cette situation difficile
appartement la sncf n'est pas dans le
déni iliad mais ses responsabilités
c'est qu'on soit un peu solidaires sur
la solution au caire en première partie
on tape sur la sncf ok il faut une
seconde partie parce qu'on s'arrête à la
première partie on n'a pas traité le
problème donc oui une première partie et
la sncf est prête à accepter les
critiques voire les coûts qu'elle mérite
mais après il faut se serrer les coudes
et ensemble trouver les meilleures
solutions possibles pour les usagers en
tout cas c'est mon état d'esprit et
c'est c'était d'esprit là d'ailleurs que
je souhaite voir se décliner un peu dans
tous les territoires devant les
difficultés que l'on peut rencontrer de
ci de là
vous m'avez tac tac tac je regarde y
avait ce sujet là les incivilités alors
suppression de trajets je les dis au nom
du plan de sobriété il y aura pas
suppressions de trains il n'y a pas que
jean pierre pernaut qui dit le ministre
des transports l'a dit très clairement
parce qu'effectivement il ya ça miroiter
un petit peu il a coupé court à la
polémique qui démarrait voilà plein de
sobriété pas de suppressions de trains
ça c'est clair les incivilités je suis
comme vous je me préoccupe elle me
préoccupe elle préoccupe les usagers
bien sûr qu'ils sont confrontés le
préoccupe nos personnels vous avez parlé
des contrôleurs ils ont les moyens
d'imiter les contrôleurs ça dépend la
situation qu'ils ont à gérer je me
souviens d'un paris beauvais ya quelques
années où notre contrôleur a été attaqué
à coups de barres de fer
bon oui voilà donc donc bon alors on a
alors c'est vrai c'est pas spécifique à
la sncf c'est un mal qui gangrène nos
sociétés il suffit de regarder la télé
télé en continu alors ça vous êtes sûr
incivilités mineurs mais on a aussi des
montées en violences des gens qui
seraient mal avait dit plus tôt voilà
c'est nouveau et on en attrape nous
mêmes on a de plus en plus de gens qui
les individus qui souhaite qu'ils se
baladaient et couteaux des lames de 30
cm
donc on a une société qui est dangereuse
et dont la dangerosité augmente ça se
voit dans les trains pour nos personnels
c'est quand même pas facile comme été un
petit peu à leur place alors ils ont un
boulot à faire ils le font on intervient
avec la suge solaire général on a trois
mille cheminots très bien formés et ans
je serai président on ne touchera pas à
ce nombre là moi je tiens absolument à
conserver toute l'efficacité de cette
force de sécurité intérieure j'allais
dire après c'est la collaboration et la
police offert des opérations de police
pour faire et c'est ce sujet très
important qui comme vous l'indiquez
pourrait nuire à l'attractivité du
ferroviaire d'enfoncer retrait la
tension est là encore
sachez qu on est on est vigilant et
actif aussi avec les
miss à l'intérieur les préfectures etc
c'est une action certaines régions nous
aide aussi on a des régions qui sont
très engagées sur ces sujets là je vais
pas les citer mais chacun pourra s'y
reconnaître parce que les régions aussi
peuvent nous aider ne serait ce qu'avec
des moyens elle et les régions rossi ont
la capacité de passer commande de
d'heures de surveillance générale
certaines régions le fond et ça nous
aide parce que ça nous avait une
substance matériel qui lui permet de
recruter davantage de personnel qu'on
peut mettre dans les trains qu'on peut
mettre dans les gares pour accentuer la
pression se devant de vent devant cesser
ces contrevenants ce sujet sérieux je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous sur
mon lution est là et l'allier alors vous
allez vous avez pensé que je me défile
c'est un peu vrai mais mais mais mais je
vais être factuel
ses traits là comme le paris limoges
comme le bordeaux marseille comme les
traits nuit
ils ont une autorité organisatrice
appelle l'état la sncf n'agit plus seul
depuis ça fait longtemps maintenant 10
ans 20 ans par là le contrat des trains
équipe du territoire aux moins de 10 ans
au moins dix ans oui ça donne ça parce
qu'on aille au moins dix ans s'est pris
dans le gallois qui avait amorcé ce jour
à cause d'un peu l'histoire parce qu'il
faut dans le clan gallois donc ça nous
remet quelques années en arrière
constaté qu'il avait plusieurs desserts
qui était nationale déficitaire
structurellement déficitaires dont le
pari clairement et ses satellites dont
paris limoges et ses satellites etc et
il se tourner vers les terres écouter
deux choses l'une où vous me passez un
contrat de service public déjà sur ses
trains où vous le faites pas je serais
obligé l'encore déjà en été dans des
logiques de rigueur budgétaire chez sont
obligés d'ajuster les dessertes en gros
de réduire le train comme l'état dans un
premier temps n'a pas répondu à sa
demande il a réduit les trains il a
réduit les trains gros scandales
politiques ont qu'a fait un peu de bazar
et donc l'état s'est dit bon finalement
on va passer un contrat avec avec la
sncf et je peux vous en parler parce que
j'étais la cheville ouvrière une des
chevilles ouvrières de ce premier
contrat donc je connais bien l'histoire
bon il ya un contrat passé avec l'état
qui vient d'être renouvelé d'ailleurs il
ya pas très longtemps contrats des
traînées qui du territoire et dans
quelle autorité organisatrice une
autorité organisatrice a fait quoi ça
décida desserte en fait c'est l'état qui
décide s'il faut aller à montluçon en
direct ou pas
si l'état nous demande d'aller à mon ex
en direct envoya les cils et ça ne
manque pas on va y aller on a pas
d'initiatives la dessert c'est eux le
matériel roulant c'est comme la région
cee et c'est
donc sur ces sujets là et c'est là vous
allez penser que je me défile un peu
j'allais dire je comprends votre
expression elle est normal les gens de
montluçon occire le droit d'avoir des
desserts de qualité pour aller à paris
ou ailleurs
la sncf peut être peut aider peut aider
en force de proposition quand même c'est
là où je remets un peu la sncf dans le
jeu et peut-être qu'une réunion avec
vous permettrait aussi de vous aider à
dire voilà type de proposition qu'on
pourrait travailler on pourrait on
pourrait et après cette matière là à
nouveau la sncf serait amené à se
retirer un petit peu et peut être vous
même pour rayer la portée auprès auprès
du ministère des transports qui est
l'autorité organisatrice en y revoilà
les les recommandations un peu travaillé
avec nous que vous pourriez peut-être
porter auprès du ministère
/
tac tac tac
collectivités alors plusieurs lièvres à
la fois ben non non non non non moi moi
je ne ferais pas ce cadeau à ceux qu'ils
m'entendent c'est pas moi qui décide
comment sa classe et c'est très bien que
les derniers je les aurais pas dont moi
c'est pas mon boulot chacun son boulot
mon boulot c'est dire ce que je pense
est nécessaire pour le système
ferroviaire français en confiance après
voilà je m'arrête après la décision de
faire ou pas faire et pour des bonnes ou
mauvaises raisons la part elle
m'appartient pas elle appartient à la
puissance publique elles appartiennent
pas jean pierre farandou près dans les
chefs dont que je me vois moi j'aime
tous mes enfants j'aime tous les enfants
du ferroviaire les transports de la vie
quotidienne le fret les lignes à grande
vitesse le réseau j'ai la conviction
profonde personnel qu'il faut s'adresser
aux adresser tous ces sujets alors que
dans le temps je peux tout à fait
comprendre que rome s'est pas fait en un
jour nous la programmation peut-être il
faut que de 15 ans 20 ans on peut tout à
fait comprendre qu'ils aient que ça peut
c'est dans le temps mais en conscience
et je m'exprime en conscience moi je
suis le l'homme du ferroviaire je suis
là pour dire ce que je pense être bon
pour mon pays en matière ferroviaire je
pense que le réseau doit être régénérée
je pense qu'il doit être modernisée je
pense qu'il faut une réponse pour la vie
quotidienne je pense qu'il faut pas
laisser tomber le fret et je pense qu'il
faut penser gagner à grande vitesse je
le pense je l'expriment la priorisation
le choix il m'appartient pas donc je le
ferai pas
peut-être mais voilà que chacun prend
ses responsabilités dans son code de
responsabilité
sur sur les collectivités locales oui
oui oui
alors on est en retard
whisky le sénateur qui va pas laisser
vous pendant alors on va être amené à
faire ces espèces de cadastre que vous
évoquez vieux qui n'existaient pas aussi
surprenant que ça puisse paraître on
était un petit peu confus sur la
maîtrise de nos deux lots 2 d'onofrio on
va le prendre par le par l'énergie par
l'énergie parce que pour savoir on peut
mettre des panneaux encore bien
connaître ces fonds si donc on appelle
ça le cadastre solaire n'a fait le
canard solaire ces cas-là ce taux courts
ont donc en fait effectivement on va
être en capacité et c'est en train
d'être fait d'avoir les idées beaucoup
plus clair sur la nature de l'eau
foncier et ensuite la question qu'on va
se poser c'est l'usagé qu'on en fait
alors les panneaux solaires peuvent être
un usage important mais pas forcément
total
il ya je vous le cache pas aussi alors
c'est plus dans les grandes villes sap
est pour nous alors modulo aussi la
manière dans les lois évoluent un
produit de cession on m'a interrogé d un
peu sur les cessions et sur le
financement j'ai par contre je voulais
pas répondre ce financement je le ferai
perdre excusez-moi et ses alliés oui de
on le fait et on va continuer à le faire
il ya des fois on accepte de vendre
propre les achats du foncier parce qu'il
a de la valeur souvent pour des
collectivités qui veulent faire des
opérations de promotion dessus ça nous
fait des rentrées financières voilà donc
une partie du foncier pas la campagne
mais dans l'est dans les très grandes
villes peut trouver une forme de
valorisation financière qui nous aident
par rapport au financement des
infrastructures c'est pas du tout mineur
c'est une source de financement
importants et puis il ya une note il ya
une partie intermédiaire qui ce qui est
à discuter mais les collectivités et on
est tout à fait prêt à le faire et je
peux vous dire que là encore depuis que
je suis arrivé chez c'est une mission
que j'ai demandé à la direction
l'immobilier d'être suffisamment
disponible pour les collectivités pour
discuter avec elle de leurs projets j'ai
des exemples concrets à auxerre à
bayonne etc etc et d'autre on a une
représentation locale de la de la
direction de l'immobilier elle est à
disposition des collectivités pour avoir
ces discussions très précise quelles
foncier pour faire quoi et dans quelles
conditions en tout cas sachez que c'est
bien une orientation que j'ai donné la
direction du mobile et ce qui me fait
dire monsieur est déçu de ma réponse sur
la je veux pas mouillé sur les priorités
mais je vais davantage m'exprimer sur
les financements parce que je peux je
peux être force de proposition comment
je résonne alors je pense qu'elle est
chose qui doit être financé par l'état
propriétaire c'est l'état qui est
propriétaire du réseau ferroviaire
français c'est le patrimoine du pays et
donc tout ce qui va être la régénération
du réseau c'est à l'état de le faire la
modération du réseau c'est à l'état sait
c'est le patrimoine
consubstantiel du pays donc ça c'est
alors c'est où le budget de l'état où la
sncf peut contribuer mes petites mains
on peut pas tout faire on le fait déjà
par le fonds de concours d'ailleurs
souvenez-vous de mécano fonds de
concours où on prend 60 % des bénéfices
réalisés par tgv geodis pour les ramener
sur le réseau voilà déjà des mécanismes
solidarité financière entre la partie
transport de la sncf et ce qu'elle y
gagne et le réseau bon est-ce qu'on peut
accentuer sa peut-être si la sncf se
porte bien s'il peut y avoir une partie
des bénéfices sncf qui peut être
réorientés vers le réseau mais ça
suffira pas d'où mon appel à un portail
budgétaire plus conséquent et plus long
sur la partie arrière régalienne du
réseau ensuite vous avez des projets les
projets je pense que ça peut discuter
les réseaux express métropolitains lâche
et une opinion que je peux me permettre
d'exprimer parce que de par mes
discussions je pense qu'elle n'est pas
déraisonnable je lui dis je pense tout à
l'heure les collectivités sont prêtes à
venir à des tours de table les régions
et les métropoles sont prêtes à
accompagner chaque projet individuel
voilà donc donc ça permet à l'état de
nos finances et qu'une partie dans une
logique de co financement du projet on
peut là aussi peut-être et ça a été un
peu abordé le sujet la fiscalité moi je
trouve que ce qu'on a fait sur la ngp
avait des taxes sur les froncés de
bureau pourquoi on le saurait pas dans
les grandes métropoles françaises pas
interdit donc là aussi il ya peut-être
une réponse fiscalité pour venir à
financer ses projets de s'effonder à de
le faire s'est fondé sur le fret
permettez-moi aussi peut-être de
corriger le chiffre que vous avez dit
peut-être quand on a pu parler de 10
milliards une époque on est plus
raisonnable le noyau dur du noyau dur
c'est 3 milliards là cela il faut
absolument les faire sinon là pour le
coup ça tombe donc on peut l'appeler je
vienne on exprime une forme de priorité
au moins sur le fret en disant l'absolu
dizaines de milliards seraient serait ce
réel serez serait super mais on en
aurait il nous en faut au moins trois
donc c'est une forme déjà je pourrais
détaillées sur les triages sur les sur
le sol avec décongestion des ports sur
la mise au gabarit de certains tunnels
etc ça c'est noyau dur pour vraiment
démarrer le développement du fret a
presque apprécié des grands
contournements on sait qui c'est
nécessaire ils sont coûteux c'est un peu
comme les lignes à grande vitesse voilà
donc
et enfin et enfin même si sur les lgv je
les dis aussi alors c'est un sujet qui
est parfois plus polémique mais moi je
considère qu'il ya pas de tabou après on
fait les choix dès lors que c'est bien
contrôlé par la puissance publique je le
répète sa patte et toujours le cas je
pense qu'il n'est pas interdit de penser
que sur certaines lignes à grande
vitesse une partie du financement pour
être apportée par du financement privé
une partie pas tout et je le redis sous
réserve du contrôle public en co
financement partiel parce que quand
c'est 100 % privé on voit ce qui se
passe sur lisea on arrive à des niveaux
de ph élevé trop élevés qui sont pas
complètement étranger à ce que vous avez
dit sur la desserte de paris bordeaux
voilà donc donc faut pas refaire ça il
faut garder le contrôle public mais une
part du financement pourraient être
apportées sur des sur des
infrastructures de grande vitesse
merci la parole et à jean michel moulod
et puis après madame avait terminé
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur farandou pour votre en parlait
pour cet appel d'ong aux 100 milliards
pour le ferroviaire donc sur sur 15 ans
je fais une petite parenthèse parce que
vous parliez de loi de programmation je
pense qu'il va y avoir une fenêtre de
tir qui va s'ouvrir puisque le
gouvernement donc a annoncé donc pour
juillet 2023 donc le fait que le
parlement serait saisie pour se
prononcer sur l'élaboration de la future
stratégie française sur le climat avec
notamment la fameuse une fameuse et
enfin une rénovation de la loi de
programmation énergie climat donc on
sera bien dans une loi de programmation
donc je pense qu'un véhicule législatif
qui va s'ouvrir d'ici d'ici l'été
prochain toujours sur la question de
l'énergie donc la sncf donc il était dit
donc consomme donc avec ses quinze mille
trains par jour entre 1 et 2% de la
consommation d'électricité annuelle de
la france donc ça représente une facture
d'un milliard d'euros on parlait tout à
l'heure en termes de pourcentage des 10%
d'électricité industrielle et on estime
que ces sept térawattheures donc cette
térawattheures c'est ce que produit je
viens en temps normal les centrales
nucléaires de 900 mégawatts donc comment
la sncf peut-elle réduire sa
consommation d'énergie donc vous avez je
dirais par rapport aux cinq pistes
possibles vous avez exclut donc la
réduction
nombre de trains vous avez également
exclu donc la réduction de la vitesse de
mis en avant ce qu'on appelle l'éco
conduite avec notamment ce logiciel aux
petits conduite donc il permet donc aux
cheminots de profité de l'inertie des
pentes vous avez également évoqué la
quatrième piste clic et le fait de
produire sa propre électricité je refais
une petite parenthèse parce que
l'article 9 de la future loi qu'on va
avoir à examiner concerne plutôt le
domaine public de l'état et pour exclure
entre guillemets des procédures de
concurrence qui sont imposées aux
propriétaires et à faudra néanmoins
regarder sur les délaissés ferroviaire
ce qui est compatible avec le code de
l'urbanisme et s'il ya besoin au-delà
des procédures dont vous avez parlé mais
qui sont déjà prévues dans d'autres
articles du code de lois de voir si ce
problème de de commandes iraj de
compatibilité avec les documents
d'urbanisme nécessite entre guillemets
de légiférer la dernière piste et bien
c'est aussi peut-être le renouvellement
du matériel donc qu'en est-il au niveau
des des tgv m puisque ceux ci sont plus
profil et donc moins consommateurs en
énergie enfin je dirais même ma dernière
question c'est y at il des augmentations
de tarifs de prévu puisque vous avez
pour l'instant pas trop de difficultés
sur l'a12 2023 puisque vous achetez à
peu près 95 % de notre électricité 2 à 3
ans l'avancement reste les 5% qu'en est
il pour les années suivantes et tout
cela va-t-il se traduire par une
augmentation de tarif et le train qui
est l'alliée du pouvoir l'allié du
climat et il l'allié du pouvoir d'achat
merci la parole à madame v merci
monsieur le président monsieur farandou
je reviendrai pas sur l'offre tarifaire
qui a été abordé tout à l'heure mais par
contre je voudrais un éclairage sur le
dispositif access plus puisque prendre
les transports en général fait partie
des défis quotidiens d'une personne en
situation de handicap une us à une
usagère en fauteuil roulant avait
témoigné en avril dernier dans la presse
locale qu'elle ne pouvait pas ajouter un
enfant sur sa commande sur la plateforme
ouïghours et
de la même façon une personne en
situation de handicap qui réserve un
trajet est aujourd'hui est elle
aujourd'hui assuré de pouvoir s'y
bénéficier du service access plus dès
l'achat de son billet puisque
visiblement il ya une confirmation
48 ou 72 heures avant de savoir si elle
peut avoir ou pas accès à ce service là
ce qui peut mettre en péril évidemment
son son trajet et puis enfin
finistérienne que je ne suis je ne peux
pas clôturer mon débat sans vous parler
de votre interview de fin juillet sur le
paris brest à 3h30 et que c'était pas si
mal je le témoignage de ce matin c'est
qu'on ne peut pas arriver à paris avant
9 heures en prenant un train 5h17 à
brest et donc on est plus proche des 4
heures pour venir que dès 3h30 et je
voudrais savoir si l'inscription du port
de brest au réseau central du réseau
transeuropéen de transport
n'applique-t-elle pas de toute façon des
travaux de modernisation sur la portion
rennes-brest je vous remercie
merci
géographiquement va changer de secteur
mais même simple et
merci président merci chez le président
farandou pour votre présence devant nous
ce matin très rapidement
mon intervention sur deux points
premièrement un besoin d'apaisement de
diamant un point d'alert besoin
d'apaisement
ça concerne gpso et une grande partie du
territoire de mon département que vous
connaissez bien les pyrénées atlantiques
toute la partie est du département au
sud de bordeaux et au sud de dax orthez
pau
lacq et une partie des hautes pyrénées
tarbes lourdes bagnères de bigorre
se trouve
être desservi par une ligne qui datent
du 19e siècle et vous l'avez évoqué
président dans vos propos liminaire donc
j'ai bien vu que vous connaissiez les
problématiques nos problématiques au sud
de bordeaux
donc
malgré l'échec j'ai envie de dire du
contrat de performance et
pouvons-nous espérer quand même que sncf
sncf réseau avec ses 2 milliards 800
millions puissent quand même faire des
travaux pour améliorer notamment les
caténaires et en tant qu'usagers du
train je me suis trouvé en carafe d'eau
trois fois à minuit en gare de dax le
train ne pouvant plus avancés dont il
s'agit de desserte de plusieurs bassins
de vie de bassins industriels également
dont ma première question pensez vous
quand même même si l'état n'apporte pas
des financements et on l'a dit pensez
vous pouvoir améliorer quand même cette
ligne qui date je le répète du 19ème
siècle est ma deuxième partie de
questions président c'est un point d'
alerte
sur le but certains élus demandent dans
mon département des pyrénées atlantiques
le rétablissement des trains de nuit or
pour avoir discuté avec des spécialistes
de la sncf si on travaille sur les
travaux de la desserte du train de nuit
ça va être détriment de gps aux dons
simplement je voudrais vous dire mon
sentiment
c'est que ce serait une hérésie ce
serait
vraiment
contre productif que d'aller mettre de
l'argent de suite sur le train de nuit
alors qu'on a des lignes dans le
département qui datent du 19e siècle et
qu'il faut absolument améliorer donc
c'est un point d' alerte que je me
permet d'exprimer devant vous président
merci merci monsieur chevrolet
perceived monsieur le président ce
président farandou merci d'avoir par les
trains et territoires territoire et
train et garantir qu'il ya toujours des
trains à desservir nos territoires et
notamment des tgv pour les
villes-centres c'est très important
notamment pour les villes préfectures je
voulais parler de mon département le
laval paris est important même si
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus de conventions
de desserte on en avait parlé lors de
votre dernière audition il ya plus cette
convention entre la sncf et les
collectivités locales mais on à votre
parole aujourd'hui du maintien et c'est
capital parce qu'on voit que les trains
de l'ouest y sont ils sont très remplie
et il est même parfois difficile
d'obtenir des places dans les rames donc
je salue l'idée qui de doubler mon
collègue a évoqué les rames du futur qui
seront importantes et j'espère que
l'ouest sera desservie donc les
préfectures c'est important vous avez
évoqué les rer est un petit peu les ter
et moi je voulais vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui dans les politiques
d'aménagement du territoire et
développement de petites villes de
demain avec des petites lignes il est
important que ces petites face et
communes rurales
bourg centre qui vont connaître un essor
de population puisse savoir aussi la
garantie d'une bonne desserte de ter à
des horaires adaptés
aux exigences du travail d'aujourd'hui
est le deuxième point que je voulais
aborder c'est la digitalisation évoqué
qu évidemment la digitalisation été
nécessaires pour faire face à la
transition écologique mais il y a en
2021 on avait voté au sénat une loi sur
la réduction de l'empreinte
environnementale du numérique donc
effectivement comment vous avez
progressé sur à la froisser de
conciliation digitalisation du groupe
tout en veillant à ce que l'empreinte
environnementale du numérique soit soit
maîtrisé merci merci cher collègue
monsieur gold merci président se brise
en finlande où vous accompagnez
certainement demain le ministre à
clermont ferrand une visite qui est très
attendu et je vais donc vous préparer à
la teneur des échanges que vous aurez si
vous venez ou que le ministre aura avec
les élus et usagers du train alors moi
je suis âgée par choix du tracé de la
ligne paris clermont chaque semaine
depuis cinq ans je vais pas vous parler
des trains qui arrivent à l'heure même
si je reconnais
globalement et sincèrement
une amélioration de la régularité depuis
cinq ans même si ce n'est pas le
ressenti évidemment pour celles et ceux
qui l'utilisent au quotidien et qui
subissent les aléas j'ai profité votre
présence au compteur pour vous lister
quelques points qui me semble encore
inacceptable notamment sur la gestion de
la crise
lorsque le train du 19 juillet mais 20
heures pour arriver de de paris à
clermont ferrand je trouve qu'il ya une
défaillance de la sncf sur la gestion de
la crise
sur l'information des passagers ensuite
je pense qu'il faudrait que vous adaptez
vos messages qui ne parle finalement
qu'aux professionnels du ferroviaire du
style incidents d'exploitation
préparation du train de terminer on a
l'impression que l'agent sncf s'est pas
réveillé le matin ou encore difficultés
d'acheminement du matériel
évitez aussi parce que c'est vécu
vraiment comme de la provocation vos sms
qui commence par je cite votre tgv
numéros etc
par exemple 10 minutes de retard qu'on
en voyage dans un corail cas plus de 40
ans on vit ça comme de la provocation
et puis autre point qui avait aussi été
vécue comme une avancée
c'est l'été la possibilité de travail on
wifi pendant les trajets aujourd'hui
sans avoir d'explication particulière
les connexions sont plus en plus fragile
et
passent parfois la moitié du trajet sans
avoir de wii fit alors j'avais aussi
quelques questions au-delà de ces
dysfonctionnements récurrents sur les
annonces en termes de régénération et de
déploiement nouvelles rames qui sont
savoir si aujourd'hui ces annonces ne
sont pas obsolète puisque les délais et
les montants étaient déjà jugés
intenables il n'avait bien sûr pas
anticipé le coup dès le coût des
matériaux de la disponibilité vous avez
déjà en partie répondu sur ce dernier
point
monsieur bigot merci chers collègues
merci monsieur le président monsieur
farandou le
merci d'abord de vos interventions de
vos observations le seul report de 10 %
de la part modale de fret et voyageurs
de la route au rail remplirait jusqu'à
un tiers de l'objectif de décarbonation
des transports de notre pays pour toutes
ces raisons on ne peut qu'approuver
votre objectif de 100 milliards
d'ailleurs le dernier rapport du haut
conseil pour le climat va dans ce sens
c'est une trajectoire qui nous paraît
pertinente
d'autres pays l'ont fait comme
l'allemagne l'italie ou les pays bas
récemment l'espagne conjugue d'ailleurs
l'investissement et des aides pour les
plus modestes avec notamment en mettant
en place un million de passes sanitaires
afin de soutenir à la fois le pouvoir
d'achat est d'économiser 360 mille
tonnes de co2 dans l'atmosphère
je voudrais vous interroger sur deux
sujets le premier c'est sur la desserte
des territoires pour réussir ce
transport modal et a certes la question
des matériels il ya aussi le réseau est
certes un sillon sont complètement
saturé
moi j'habite dans une région par exemple
nantes angers ou angers nantes on va pas
pouvoir augmenter indéfiniment le trafic
sans créer de nouvelles infrastructures
ferroviaires donc quel
soutien apporté vous aux collectivités
territoriales qui ont besoin d expertise
pour transférer pour transformer les
mobilités et renforçait donc ce report
modal sur le ferroviaire et puis je
voudrais vous poser une question sur
l'énergie vous avez un certain nombre de
choses ont été dites donc je ne ferai
pas de redite mais vous avez indiquée
lors d'une précédente audition
parlementaire la piste d'être à
hydrogène avez vous avancé sur ses
solutions avec les industriels où en
êtes vous je remercie
si jacques avec madame grès ville puis
monsieur dagbert
merci merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur farandou pour votre présence
votre écoute et vous futurs réponse
alors donc comme ça a été évoqué
effectivement pour atténuer le
changement climatique nous sommes en
train de vivre l'une des solutions est
la promotion et avec une certaine
urgence du ferroviaire voyageurs fret
tout compris en quelque sorte il nous
faudrait un choc de l'offre pour changer
les habitudes et nous faire préférer le
train comme c'était le slogan je crois
lors d'une campagne de publicité pour la
sncf
à ce titre alors je ne sais pas comme je
suis arrivé un petit peu en retard si
vous en aviez parlé lors de votre propos
liminaire qu'avez vous pensé de l'offre
cet été en allemagne d'un abonnement
pour 9 euros sur tous les transports
régionaux est ce que c'est une bonne
idée j'ai cru comprendre que s'il avait
eu beaucoup de succès est-ce que vous
avez pour vous il vous a semblé que
c'était judicieux ou pas il y avez vous
songé
et quelles auraient été les impacts
voulu ou pas de cette cet abonnement à 9
euros donc sur tout le territoire
national ensuite j'ai bien sûr en tant
que sénatrice du lot des questions à
vous poser sur des inquiétudes que nous
avons au sujet de notre ligne polt paris
orléans limoges toulouse et sur les
travaux de régénération
nous sommes inquiets sur le délai
pouvait vous peut-être nous rassurer
ensuite d'attirer votre attention mais
j'ai bien compris par la réponse que
vous dites que vous avez donnée que sur
sept sur sept lignes ça n'est pas vous
qui décidez d arrêt c'est bien ça voilà
c'est l'état mais malgré tout je tiens
quand même à vous dire que beaucoup de
trains s'arrêtent à brive mais que mon
département donc est délaissé puisque
toulon département est traversée par
cette ligne qui va jusqu'au sud à cahors
puis plus loin à toulouse et que voilà
on est un petit peu oublié dans le dans
la sphère ensuite sur les trains de nuit
il ya un train de nuit prévu paris
aurillac qui devrait être rentré en
circulation alors fin 2022 ou 2023
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire nous
donner une date ou pas et puis attirer
votre attention également c'est un autre
sujet sur la constante diminution des
effectifs des personnels hangar qui pose
problème et notamment dans les
territoires ruraux pour beaucoup de
personnes qui ne disposent pas
d'internet ou pour les personnes âgées
qui sont nombreux dans mon département
il ya un département de troisième le
plus
disons au niveau vieillissement
donc voilà est-ce que c'est des choses
des pistes sur lesquelles vous
travaillez ou pas c'est vrai que mon
dépenses de personnel c'est toujours
très important et enfin une dernière
question que qui me vient au sujet des
des friches ou des délaissés est-ce que
vous avez déjà une idée parce que j'ai
bien compris que vous travaillez sur ce
sujet sur le pourcentage de l'immobilier
que vous avez qui seraient concernés par
ces délaissés est ce que ce sont et je
ne pense pas des sols forcément
imperméabilisées est ce qu est est ce
que vous savez déjà où vous avez pensé à
répertorier les éventuels accès et 6 et
du photovoltaïque est ce que ce serait
de l'autoconsommation à la solution qui
serait adoptée dans ce cas là et enfin
une question sur le matériel roulant
parce que j'ai lu quelque part que
le matériel roulant français du ray en
fait deux fois moins qu'en allemagne
est ce que c'est le même matériel ou pas
est ce qu'il y aurait voilà sur la
maintenance ou des peut-être des progrès
à faire et enfin toute petite dernière
question parce que sur mon département
il ya la société au rail cup où en
êtes-vous sur les relations vous
entretenez avec vos concurrents
et sur les difficultés qu'ils ont pu
rencontrer par le passé voilà merci
merci chef collègue monsieur dagobert
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président
vous avez entendu depuis le début de
cette audition bon nombre de mes
collègues vous interrogez est pointé un
certain nombre de difficultés
rencontrées dans chacun de nos
territoires c'est dire l'attachement des
membres de cette commission à
l'entreprise qui est la vôtre monsieur
le président c'est une presque passion
égale à celle qui vous anime que nous
partageons nous avons tendance à pointer
du doigt le verre à moitié vide je vais
me permettre de pointer le verre à
moitié plein ayant eu la chance de
participer aux côtés du ministre des
transports qui s'appelait elisabeth
borne à l'époque à l'inauguration de la
ligne de ferroutage calais le boulou et
orbassano doit redémarrer en 2023 ayant
eu la chance également de visiter
l'investissement conséquent d'une
entreprise familiale qui exploite une
carrière importante qui est la carrière
du boulonnais et qui est très active
dans le projet du grand paris puisque
elle bénéficie d'un accès à proximité
des bords de seine et donc elle a fait
un investissement conséquent sur son
terminal de fret pour acheminer
notamment les granulats jusque presque
dans le centre de paris par le train et
enfin dernier motif de satisfaction
j'étais aux côtés de mon président de
région des hauts de france lundi dernier
et aux côtés de luc lallemand pour la
fin des travaux de l'étoile de la
régénération de l'étoile de saint pol
sur ternoise donc voilà au moins trois
bonnes raisons qui me permettent
d'intervenir aujourd'hui pour dire que
les choses bougent elles ne bougent pas
assez vite à notre à notre volonté au
rythme qui serait souhaitable y compris
pour l'ensemble des clients du fret
comme pour l'ensemble des clients
du trafic voyageurs néanmoins on sent
quand même cette volonté d'aller de
l'avant vous n'avez pas évoquer la
reprise de la dette et je pense que ça
mériterait quand même que vous nous
fassiez un petit éclairage sur ce point
parce que vous avez manifestement des
besoins d'investissements conséquents
mais vous avez aussi rappeler en quoi
les régions où les métropoles peuvent
aider dans les transports du quotidien à
la résolution d'un certain nombre de
difficultés que rencontrent nos
concitoyens eu égard à l'engorgement de
ces dites métropole qui
chacun de nous le sait bien sont appelés
à voir toujours plus leurs actifs leur
attractivité croissante voilà les justes
point que je souhaitais sur lesquels je
souhaitais intervenir si cher collègue
monsieur le président je vous propose de
répondre à cette dernière série de
questions
[Musique]
merci pour votre intérêt effectivement
que des tas de questions pertinentes sur
toutes les facettes du monde ferroviaire
et de la sncf dont l'énergie
oui c'est vrai j'ai fait un gros
consommateur d'électricité bien
évidemment d'autant mieux l epa
carbonées dans le pays donc c'est pour
ça qu'elle est écologique si on faisait
l'électricité avec du charbon on aurait
un problème comme on le fait avec du
nucléaire pas suffisamment bon le fait
et j'espère demain avec erwin dernier
renouvelables on a un bon mix & electric
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que le projet qu'on
accorde que la discuter donc concerne
pas encore complètement mais il ya un
potentiel important je pense qu'en phase
une on serait pas loin d'un
térawattheures donc on a vraiment un
terrain sur cette accessible qu'aux
n'est viable ça fait 15 % quand même et
il faut poursuivre les études la
technologie notamment de panneaux
solaires longitudinaux comme pour
installer lion des voix et pas comme un
train de caler mais c'est le potentiel
c'est prometteur là c'est prometteur
donc selon les hypothèses et selon le
niveau d'optimisme mais on peut quand
même
parié là dessus je dis pas dans tout de
suite mais la sncf pourrait finalement
produire une quantité significative
d'électricité verte loin d'être
négligeable par rapport à sa
consommation alors après la modalité est
ce qu'on auto consommons est ce qu'on
voit au réseau et cetera n'est pas calé
il ya encore plein modèle est en année
on n'a pas encore déterminé ça fait
partie d'ailleurs des compléments
d'études que nous devons faire mais
c'est la question m'a été posée donc
j'ai pas la réponse mais mais voilà il
ya eu on sent qu'on tient quelque chose
voilà on tient quelque chose je pense de
primordial à la fois pour le ferroviaire
très compatible à la fois de d'ailleurs
parce que si on apporte nous mêmes des
solutions énergétiques pour le
ferroviaire ça ça ne fait que consolider
la perspective de croissance est évoquée
sur les
sur les tarifs alors effectivement alors
je vais légèrement nuancé votre approche
effectivement heureusement pour nous on
a une scène de couverture comme vous
l'avez dit ça qu'on avait acheté à
l'avancé les tricité à prix convenu et
ses prix convenu sont bien en dessous
des prix spot donc ça bien nous en a
pris sinon la facture ont été terribles
ont malgré ça malgré ce niveau de
couverture important on a dès cette
année une croissance de la facture
électrique de 300 millions quand même
quand même pas négligeable
et comment oui c qui a doublé on avait
prévu 300 on est passé on est passé on
est passé à 6 ans sur les tricité et
l'année prochaine on est toujours
couvert mais un peu moins est alors bien
sûr comme c'est très volatil mais avec
le prix du moment on aurait à ce stade
sur coup que la soeur électricité 2
milliard 6 mars est donc alors remboursé
la moitié pour les tv la moitié pour les
ter et transilien c'est moitié moitié
entre
bon alors les théories le transilien
c'est une discussion complexe qu'on a
devant nous avec les collectivités
puisque par le mécanisme d'un index ce
surcoût d'énergie va se retrouver dans
la facture des collectivités qui des
régions qui vont
c'est significatif ça fait plusieurs
dizaines de millions d'euros par an pour
chacune des régions c'est quand même des
coûts significatifs donc les difficultés
économiques qui apparaît bien évidemment
sur le tgv ou là c'est nous avec nous on
a fait les calculs de coin table sur ont
répercuté directement sur le coût du
billet on va pas faire je vous rassure
mais c'est que vous ayez un peu l'idée
on serait amenée à augmenter les billets
tgv de 10% pour répercuter le lait cette
somme de 800 900 millions d'euros
supplémentaires en énergie on va pas le
faire évidemment d'abord en un peu le
sens de l'intérêt général et
deuxièmement c'est très bien que ça
tuerait la les volumes il ya une
élasticité au prix il ne peut pas
augmenter les prix comme ça bon preuve
n'a pas encore décidé ce qu'on allait
faire je vous cache pas que le
gouvernement suisse à peu près aussi on
le comprend donc c'est un sujet sensible
on n'a pas décidé on va discuter
est-ce qu on augmente ou pas et à quel
niveau et comment en plus il ya
plusieurs modalités pour augmenter il ya
plusieurs modalités voilà c'est un sujet
qui est posé sur la table qui est encore
pas complètement calé ne serait ce parce
qu'on n'a pas encore fiabiliser le
niveau du coût de l'énergie de l'année
prochaine mais mais mais rassurez vous
on répercutera pas 100 % des coûts sur
les clients ça je peux prendre cet
engagement dès aujourd'hui sur le
pouvoir d'achat c'est vrai que j'ai eu
la question plusieurs fois
je plaide non-coupable là dessus bien
des fois je plaide coupable sur amiens
sur clermont est coupable je reconnais
les difficultés coupable prob discuter
sur les responsabilités réciproques mais
je vais revenir sur clermont je l'évoqué
sur la picarde sur les tarifs je joue
toujours mieux faire en peinture ont
pointé des choses un peu curieuse mais
honnêtement cet été trois billets en a
vendu 23 millions de billets cet été 23
millions 3 sur 4 était à prix réduits 3
sur 4
la carte avantages on en a vendu presque
4 millions la carte avantages c'est ce
qui permet d'éviter à ce que certains
d'entre vous ont signalé ces relais pays
management iv voilà la carte avantages
lkp le prix 39 59 79 selon la longueur
39 cas une heure et demie
59 en une heure et demie et trois heures
et au delà bordeaux par exemple
s'entraîner trois heures donc au maximum
la carte avantages même le jour le plus
de gros départs vous paierez 59 euros si
vous avez carte avantages ses capés
donc on a des réponses wiggo will go on
a un billet c'est 25% de l'activité tgv
c'est plus négligeable des we go ces 25
euros c'est la moitié des prix serait un
gros on a parlé des we go train
classique qui est aussi une réponse sur
les petits prix et enfin il ya ça c'est
l'absolue et puis y'a le relatif quand
vous regardez le prix dans les autres
pays
c'est à dire que les prix des trains des
trains français soit cher je ne parle
même pas des tarifications régionales ça
dépend pas laisser m et honnêtement
toutes les régions toutes jouent le jeu
de prix accessibles sur leur territoire
et franchement les prix des ter ils sont
accessibles quand on voit effectivement
ce qui se passe ailleurs donc voilà donc
moi je vous fais une réponse un peu
global mais vous sentez que là dessus je
résisterai dans le débat voilà parce que
je trouve c'est c'est un peu c'est pas
fidèle à la réalité alors on peut
toujours pointé un truc alors je vous
deux ans donnait au moins voilà pour
vous dire je suis honnête
intellectuellement il ya un truc est
anormal vous aviez je n'ai qu'à la
résoudre bon on peut employer la carte
avantages ou pas sur les we go c'est
d'ordre sur les we go vous avez des line
management un peu fou oui sur les we go
comme la carte avantages s'applique pas
là vous avez encore sur ses trains et
c'est très paradoxal parce que des low
cost en plus normalement vous avez
encore des effet d'emballement du
management sur les who je reconnais que
le monde n'est pas parfait et qu'on a
encore quelques sujets quelques sujets
de travail mais je voudrais qu'elle
causait une appréciation peut être un
peu plus nuancé de la politique de prix
menée par la sncf en plus que moins
depuis que celui-là j'essaye encore
ajustements une politique de volume très
cohérente avec le foie de passe que vous
faire le faux de faux du volume voilà
donc j'essaie de rester dans cette ligne
là et je vois qu'elle n'est pas encore
parfaitement perçu par la collectivité
donc on a du boulot on a du boulot
pédagogique et on essaiera de le faire
sur alors je ne sais pas forcément dans
l'or sur le gpso et les lignes
classiques qui vont au tour oui c'est un
projet global est bien d'accord avec
vous qu'il faut comprendre gpso pas
seulement comme la construction de
lignes nouvelles bordeaux toulouse avec
son antenne vers dax mais bien
évidemment le réseau ferroviaire qui est
en aval vers le sud-ouest vers vers
bayonne vers pau etc doit aussi faire
partie de l' approche globale voilà donc
je pensais comme ça qu'il faut le
concevoir en tout cas c'est comme ça que
j'ai cessé le conçois mais mais la
réponse à votre question elle est bien
dans un ensemble il faut accrocher la
rénovation du réseau classique au projet
gpso dans une vision d'ensemble
d'amélioration globale du ferroviaire
dans le dans le grand sud ouest dans le
grand sud ouest en se servant de la
ligne nouvelle comodin d'un moteur de
quelque chose qui entraîne le reste
voilà vous avez raison de le pointer je
prends votre alerte merci de me la de
m'avoir alerter je la prends pour le
pont là pour la pour la traiter alors je
suis pas forcément dans l'ordre excusez
moi parce que j'ai posé mes fiches
devant moi
donc ça c'est comme la dernière
forcément je vais quand même pas la
prendre maintenant je vais prendre
clairement
clairement j'allais un peu évoquée alors
je vais pas anticiper sur la discussion
de demain le ministre se déplace on va
laisser aux ministres faire les annonces
qui souhaitent faire
merci d'avoir noté que la régularité
s'améliorer et je suis malheureusement
je suis d'accord avec vous que c'est pas
la perception des usagers donc voilà
c'est comme ça c'est un peu la même
réponse que 2k montluçon et vous le
savez en tant qu'élu du territoire ont
fait avec locomotive kona elles sont
anciennes les voitures connaît les voies
connaît
alors on fait au mieux à nous de faire
au mieux et je sens dans votre
intervention que sur le la réalité
ferroviaire vous l'a cerné assez bien
vous avez raison nous interpeller sur
les à-côtés comco l'information
voyageurs et la prise en charge là vous
avez raison parce que ça c'est pas dans
le dur c'est des choses qui peuvent et
doivent s'améliorer le libé les annonces
au sol dit nous mêmes et je peux vous
dire que ma vérité de cabinet qui a
encore le regard neuf de quelqu'un qui
n'est pas cheminots de première langue
m'a fait remarquer que comme vous que
nous annonce était très techno et que
les jurés aient fait l'équipe doit pas
comprendre et comme ils comprennent pas
quand c'est flou il ya un loup enfin
bref on laisse que l'anecdote que vous
racontez vous êtes dans un pari que
clairement on parle sms de tgv c'est
quand même faute de goût faute de goût
évidente non merci de attiré notre
attention lathus à ces choses qu'on doit
corriger vite je vous trouve un peu
sévère dans votre présentation de le
train pas mis 20 heures il a été annulé
les voyageurs vivent enter sa stature
pas le train le train n'a été annulé
alors quand on dit que le train mais 20
heures dans l'impression d'un exode les
voyageurs with only event heures puisque
on a dû les ramener sur paris il endormi
à paris sont repartis le lendemain bon
pour vous consoler ça nous arrive aussi
sur le tgv ce genre de mésaventure s'est
pas spécifique aux paraît clairement il
nous arrive
trop souvent à mon goût d'avoir des
comme ça des retards incroyables
parce que les pépins s'accumulent etc
etc voilà bon à ce qu'on peut les éviter
peut-être il faut accepter l'idée que le
mieux la meilleure des choses et les
éviter et en tout cas s'il arrive
soigner l'information soigner la prise
en charge que les gens sont pas
délaissés dans mercy d'attirer notre
attention là dessus vous avez
entièrement raison mais santé quand même
qu'on lâche pas la faire leur numéro
général on n'est pas parfait non lâche
pas la faire il renonce pas à
s'améliorer et on n'est pas dans le déni
mais en contrepartie on souhaite que les
notamment au niveau la réserve nationale
vous compreniez bien toutes les facettes
d'un sujet qui parfois plus complexes
qu'il en a l'air
sûr alors peut-être handicap jeu c'est
important lundi qu'à manager pas la
réponse précise à votre question on va
vous la donner là aussi entendez la part
du président qu'on veut être
irréprochable sur le transport des
handicapés les handicapés ont le droit
de voyager ont le droit de voyager en
train d'amorcer la loi qui le dit mais
au delà de la loi ils ont le droit de
voyager voilà donc on va vous apporter
les réponses à vos questions et on sera
vigilant à ce que les améliorations
peut-être de service que vous avez
apporté puissent être traités c'est un
sujet important on veut le traité bien
évidemment
tahri on a parlé les ter bien sûr dans
les cieux oui mais je suis complètement
face sur votre première partie de
d'intervention sur le numérique vous
avez raison dans le plan de sortie était
on s'est rendus on le savait mais ça
nous oblige à nous rendre compte que le
digital consomme beaucoup d'énergie les
mails par exemple donc là on va avoir
une approche volontariste pour réduire
le nombre de mails et l'ampleur des
mails avec des pièces jointes et tout le
bazar ça consomme énormément donc vous
avez entièrement raison d'appeler notre
vigilance et le plan de sobriété est une
bonne occasion je veux dire de se
regarder les sujets en face et être plus
volontariste dans l'ain dans l'action
pour avoir aussi une sobriété
énergétique sur le digital raison de le
pointer c'est peut-être insuffisant dans
notre plan actuel et je peux m'engager
devant vous à le travailler davantage
entièrement raison je prends le point on
va le faire
oui alors ça c'était là je crois les
billes à 9 euros etc oui c'est la choc
de l'offre de faire paraître un bon goût
oui vous avez compris que c'est ce que
je veux faire avec foi de jeu faire un
choc de l'offre je suis entièrement là
dedans donc on est tout à fait d'accord
philosophie le 9 euros
mon opinion est mitigé alors oui un
effet d'attraction baignable il
semblerait que les bilans qui sont faits
au fond c'est plus une mesure pouvoir
d'achat qu'une mesure report modal le
pouvoir d'achat oui c'est moins cher les
gens sont contents ça donne voilà le
report modal n'est pas massif en tout
cas parce qu'il faut traiter l'offre
toujours pareil c'est pas aussi si vous
visez les gens qui sont dans la voiture
si vous n'êtes pas une alternative en
interne offre ils vont rester dans la
voiture le 9 euros et pas forcément
suffisant assez ça au fond mais mais
mais mais pour autant ces a pu créer des
afflux snm pas les afflux ça peut créer
des afflux massifs sur certains jours
certains week-ends où la db les chemins
de fer allemands était embarrassée parce
qu'il n'avait pas assez de capacité ça
fait venir énormément de monde savait
pas les transporter personne n'est
content we dance et à manipuler avec
précaution voilà bilan mitigé après il
m'appartient pas de me décider de ce
qu'on doit faire ou pas faire ce sujet
la
sueur
/ alors ce que vous avez entendu sur la
durée de vie des matériels roulants en
france est au c est pareil en allemagne
ses 40 ans en gros les tgv qu'on les
mettait régionaux et d'ailleurs on fait
des opérations me villain pour ceux qui
sont d'à peu près dans toutes les
régions au bout de 20 ans me vie on fait
des opérations assez lourde pour
redonner du potentiel en confort et en
sécurité pour les rames donc là tu vois
là non il n'y a pas de ya pas de point
particulier j'ai on n'a pas à rougir de
la maintenance qu'on fait en france tu
peux qu'elle est bonne qualité rail coop
ont leur pas de mal mais voilà c'est
compliqué pour eux bon on va après voilà
bordeaux lyon 72 500 c'est compliqué ce
compliqué voilà mes mais on ne veut pas
de mal on les laisse on leur parle on
essaie d'arranger le problème quand on
le peut mais objectivement ça reste
compliqué voilà moi j'ai pas j'ai pas
ingéré la complexité de des entreprises
qui choisit de faire du ferroviaire en
france il découvre le ferroviaire je
pense qu'ils ont en phase
d'apprentissage long de la complexité du
ferroviaire bon voilà c'est un chemin
qui doit faire un peu douloureux
visiblement mais voilà on laisse pas
tomber le lot c'est polt ce pôle c'est
l'équivalent de paris clairement c'est
pareil c'est la même logique
ce que vous dites est vrai
de la même manière dans le lot c'est un
peu ce sont deux programmes similaires
le pari clairement le pari limogés au
delà en la fois sur l'infrastructure et
c'est du matériel roulant c'est les
mêmes matériels roulants qui seront
déployés à la fois sur la ligne polt sur
la ligne clairement donc c'est se voit
donc c'est les mêmes symptômes
et là-dessus comme je les dis à au
collet qui plaidait pour montluçon si
vous plaidez pour les arts et les arrêts
dans l'autre il faut
monter vos demandes auprès d'autorités
organisatrices et défendez votre
territoire auprès de du bon du bon
interlocuteur
le pari aurillac je crois que c'est pour
la fin de l'année enfin vous le
confirmera mais moi j'ai ça en tête donc
c'est un engagement du premier ministre
jean castex 1 qui donc on va le tenir
territoires ruraux et distribution c'est
un vaste sujet
comme toujours un peu compliqué vous
êtes tout à fait légitimes à dire que
les gens souhaiteraient qui est du
personnel dans les gares tout le temps
dans les territoires très haut ils vont
ils finissent par vendre très peu de
billets yvan de 7 8 billets par jour ils
s'ennuient
ils s'ennuient en termes du de même pour
l'agencé long dont il finit par lire des
bouquins regarder la télé fait
l'utilité personnel de cet agent est
contestée des moyens coup le coût est
payé par les régions les régions font
attention à l'argent du contribuable ça
se questionne cette question il faut
accepter cette question en tout cas
alors les pistes pour les gars pas trop
petit des petits bourgs une première
idée c'est la mutualisation est ce que
dans la gare on peut mutualiser
l'ensemble de service ou une personne
ferait tout mais dans la gare y compris
20 des billets pour ça c'est une
première idée on a des expérimentations
qui commença à pointer ou mutualistes
des choses et on partage le personnel du
coup et la scala sur le mutualisent on
arrive à trouver une forme de d'utilité
plus forte à la fois ils s'ennuient -
est à la fois en termes de coûts on
l'aurait parties à plusieurs voilà donc
ça c'est une bonne idée héros fait de la
guerre en lieu de centralité d'ailleurs
voilà une vraie idée d'aménagement du
territoire petite ville fo comme davy de
fauw débours quand c'est trop trop rural
on a un problème parce que bon voilà
deuxièmement n'oubliez pas le téléphone
il ya toujours le téléphone les gens
oublient le téléphone voilà ville bravo
à lille et merci olivier
le 32 35 est toujours là les gens
oublient qu'on peut encore appeler alors
bien sûr peut-être pas assez minutes
avant le départ c'est compliqué mais la
veille pour le lendemain une personne
âgée par exemple qu'il serait pas trop
bien servir du minitel et souvent ils
savent téléphoner comme bailly téléphone
voilà donc ça il est bon il peut donc ça
je pense qu'il ya cette réponse du
téléphone qu'on a un peu oublié mais qui
est toujours là qui est toujours là
voilà ça c'est ça et puis et puis il me
reste le meilleur pour la fin
merci de l'attachement bruit et je
comprends que ça ça nous ça nous oblige
quelque part et mais aussi ça nous
soutient voilà enfin il y aurait rien de
pire que s'il est à la colonne à
s'intéresser pas offert au maire on
serait embêté vous y intéresser
vous faites remonter le niveau
d'exigence et c'est bien normal mais au
moins ça crée une dynamique sacré
quelque chose de porteurs pour l'avenir
merci aussi de voir la bouteille à
moitié pleine ça fait du bien de temps
en temps aussi donc de mettre un peu
positifs à partir des réalisations
concrètes que vous avez pu que vous avez
plus qu constater c'est vrai c'est vrai
que les choses quand même bouge malgré
tout il ya quand même aussi des choses
qui avancent et puis sur la reprise de
la dette alors que vous souhaitez que je
l'évoquent un peu plus donc c'est une
partie forte de la loi de 2018 c'était
35 milliards d'euros de la dette des snf
réseau dont on se souvient que le motif
principal c'est la construction du tgv 1
voilà je reste en cfa dépenser 100
milliards en 40 ans pour le tgv donc
qu'on lui en gros 80 milliards sur le
réseau et 20 milliards sur les matériels
roulants et les gars bon les ateliers
donc au fond qui est une forme de
reprise de ce montant là n'est pas
complètement déraisonnables en tout cas
tout cas c'est justifié en tout cas s'il
était fait ça n'a jamais été fait avant
ça a un effet c'est un effet très
concret sur les frais financiers ça
réduit les frais financiers mais
d'autant en gros deux milliards par an
pour ses pas négligeable ça redonne de
l'air dans le fameux 2008 dont on parle
et que ces réseaux investi il ya un
milliard déjà qui vient c'est un
allégement des frais financiers donc
c'est conséquent quand je rappelle quand
même ça je vous le dit tout à l'heure
mais ça me permet de le redire que c'est
pas gratuit ou c'est pas neutre
puisqu'en contrepartie de cet allègement
l'actionnaire état m'a demandé de mener
une trajectoire de retour à l équilibre
rigoureuse ça veut dire économie
productivité c'est pas des mots tabous
elle est sincère et on le fait et on le
fait on est sur le chemin il ya une
contrepartie on vous aide en tant
qu'actionnaire état mais on vous demande
de la rigueur et de la gestion efficace
et on le fait on le fait bien volonté
c'est l'argent public et on respecte
argent public je respecte argent public
voilà sur le sur les tours de table je
les dis aussi je suis convaincu que sur
wii sur l'hydrogène faut que j'en parle
sur les tours de table en tout cas pour
les projets de réseaux expression et
j'en ai parlé à plusieurs régions je
vais pas les citer j'en ai parlé à
plusieurs présidents de métropole je
vais pas les citer il serait prêt à
venir si l'état prenne une initiative en
disant voilà on vient vous voir on est
prêt à financer la moitié du projet est
ce que vous collectivités régions
métropole vous faites vous faites le
complément on a une chance on a une
chance d'y arriver voilà j'en suis
intimement convaincu donc c'est pas tout
apporté par l'état c'est la question qui
m'a été posée tout n'est pas apportée
par l'état dans le fameux 100 milliards
que j'évoquais
enfin oui excusez moi je sais peut-être
je vais oublier de le dire le train à
hydrogène oui j'y crois alors le train à
hydrogène il permet d'euros bouclée
finalement sur la sncf acteurs la
transition écologique
le le mondial la partie sombre du du
discours c'est le diesel on a encore 20%
de nos trains fret et voyageurs qui sont
thermiques qui sont au diesel problème
ça peut pas il faut le traiter alors on
va le traiter on a l'ambition de le
traiter complètement d'ici 2050 même
avant donc oui on a compris qu'il
fallait se passer du diesel deux étapes
l'étape du moment c'est avec des
solutions qui existent et on peut faire
des choses très hybride moitié les
criques moitié disent elles ça existe
dans l'industrie très au colza on le
fait sur paris granville j'ai passé les
sénateurs normand parmi nous voilà
comment voilà c'est mérité voilà mais en
tout cas voilà on le fait bien sûr oui
il ya des sujets aussi on le fait
très électrique à batterie on va le
faire sur on va le faire entre aix en
provence et marseille
voilà donc on a des solutions existantes
compte déploie avec des régions bien sûr
assez les régions qui financent au soit
clair assez pâle sncf qui finance s'est
fait conseiller technique ont fait la
maintenance etc mais l'investissement
est décidée par la part les régions
elles le font sur l'hydrogène pour moi
c'est l'étape suivante l'hydrogène au
point de vue le point de vue technique
des trains qui marchent à l'hydrogène ça
existe déjà pas beaucoup mais ça existe
elle somme en fait qui roulent en
allemagne ont narré joli ce qu'on est en
train de mettre au point et je suis
convaincu qu ça se fera donc en fait le
sujet sera pas tellement mais des
moteurs à hydrogène dans des trains ça
on va y arriver par contre la cruelle ce
qui est pas fait c'est produire
massivement de l'hydrogène verte verte
il est pas trop cher parce que ça va
rentrer dans le bilan est distribuée
partout sur le territoire parce que les
ter par définition ils sont partout sur
le territoire là on n'y est pas donc le
gros challenge de l'hydrogène c'est ça
si ça c'est fait je suis pas inquiet on
aura des trains à hydrogène dans le pays
hélas le zéro émissions nettes on va y
arriver parce que justement on pourra se
passer du diesel dont le vrai challenge
est hélas alors est-ce qu'on peut être
confiant sur ce challenge oui oui
pourquoi parce que d'abord l'état joue
le jeu il ya une filière hydrogène il
met de l'argent sur l'hydrogène il faut
qu'ils continuent bien sûr et on a la
chance en france d'avoir quatre grandes
entreprises quatre grands énergéticiens
qui veut les y aller on a l'air liquide
c'est celui qu'on connaît le moins mais
c'est le leader mondial de l'hydrogène
air liquide il est français verseront je
crois qu'il veut créer des installations
hydrogène sur rouen où l'arbre donc donc
il y aura des installations de
production d'hydrogène je crois que
s'ils veulent commencer par voilà sur la
vallée de seine on a aidé à ce qu'il
veut y aller on a une vie qui veut y
aller on à total qui veut y aller voilà
on a quatre grandes entreprises qui sont
puissantes qui veulent aller dans la
production d'hydrogène on a un
gouvernement qui a compris que c'était
important voilà donc on peut être
raisonnable en confiant que d'ici 10 15
ans et ça tombe bien c'est la durée de
vie du matériel régionaux actuels donc
là 10 15 ans devant nous on peut tenir
faisons le pari raisonné et raisonnable
que dans 15 ans on aura traiter ce
problème industriel est donc là on
pourra déployer massivement l'hydrogène
et ce qui évitera d'électrifier les
lignes on n'aura pas besoin
d'électrifier les vignes parce qu'on
aura des engins qui pourront rouler sur
des lignes non électrifiées à
l'hydrogène
et un merci et
de deux heures des changes 2h02 de
dialogue deux heures de questions
réponses avec des réponses franches
claires précises avec je crois un
sentiment commun c'est celui bien
entendu de l'attachement du président
directeur général à la sncf mais aussi
vous l'aurez compris l'attachement que
porte notre commission a au ferroviaire
à la sncf et dans les débats que nous
aurons prochainement et je ne doute pas
que que nos collègues que mes collègues
interviendront pour effectivement essayé
de faire évoluer
l'accompagnement qu'on peut apporter à
la sncf parce que on l'a bien compris si
on veut aménager nos territoires si on
veut développer nos territoires si on
veut émettre moins de gaz à effet de
serre ben il faudrait bien qu'on s'en
donne les moyens et je crois qu'à
travers le transport qui est l'un des
éléments aujourd'hui le le plus polluant
je crois que la sncf est un excellente
élève et je crois que nous aurons toutes
et tous à coeur et nous serons toutes et
tous attachés à défendre l'intérêt qui
est celui de la sncf mais l'intérêt qui
est celui de l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens sur ce territoire national
merci monsieur le président pour nous
avoir consacré tout ce temps et pour
avoir répondu franchement à nos
questions merci